Oh,
sweet baby.
Jesus.
We're back again.
Ladies and gentlemen,
this a episode of the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by
Squarespace.
What's that,
Joe Rogan.
Why am I talking about myself in the third person?
I've been bored with these things.
Squarespace is a new sponsor and it's a very cool,
when I'm excited about it,
it's an extremely easy way to build an awesome website.
Everything is integrated.
You just go online and,
and the whole setup is there for you.
Like you don't have to learn coding,
you know,
to learn html.
It's super intuitive how they do it.
And you don't even have to spend money to try it.
If you go there,
sign up,
go to squarespace.com,
forward slash Joe,
no credit card needed.
You just try it.
Start building your website.
You can create your own online store.
It's really bad ass.
24,
seven support,
really responsive design.
Your,
your site will look great on any device.
IPAD,
iPhone,
android.
You get a free domain name if you sign up for a year.
Um,
then if you decide to use it,
you go,
um,
go to squarespace.com,
forward slash Joe if you want to use it,
you say,
Hey,
you know what?
I tried this out.
I like it.
I'm going to make a website here and I'm gonna put it online.
Use the Code Joe Three.
It's three,
because now we're in a bunch of mark.
I don't know why they decided to have the number with the correlating with the
mark talking months.
Yeah,
the month of March,
Mum,
a month of March rather muncho Marth munch of Martin Luther moochers month of
March.
If you use the code Joe Three,
you will get 10% off your first purchase on new accounts,
including monthly and annual plants.
So that's squarespace.com.
Forward Slash Joe,
use the offer code [inaudible] all one word,
Joe and the number three.
All right,
your fucking base.
Everything you need to create an exceptional website
and if you want to sell something,
they have a shop,
a feature that you can just pretty much sell anything you want to.
And it's really easy to upload images and it's super easy to create your own
online store
super fast.
So check it out.
It's a very cool website.
We're also brought to you by Ting Tang is,
as we said on the podcast,
if we're selling something,
it's,
it's always going to be a good product.
We're not selling anything that's dog shit.
Um,
and we also wouldn't,
one of the things that we like is companies that have a good ethic behind them
and I've never even heard of a company like Tang before.
The waiting is with Ting is a cell phone company that uses the sprint backbone,
but they have no contracts and the way they have it set up,
you can buy all high end android phones.
They have the Samsung Galaxy s three,
the galaxy note to all those like serious killer android phones.
Well,
when you,
when you use them,
like say if you,
you know,
you have a plan that has x amount of minutes.
If you don't use a certain amount of service,
you use less than you thought you would take to actually drops you down.
So you hit credits and credits you the difference on your next bill.
So that mean that is like,
I've never even heard of that before.
They actually drop you down to the next level and they credit you the difference
in money.
I mean,
that's amazing.
That's a,
it's a beautiful company.
I think companies,
some companies like Tang are starting to realize,
do you don't have to rip people off to make money.
You don't have to extract every last drop of blood out of them to make money.
What you can do is offer people a good service within an ethical ideal behind
it.
And uh,
no,
try to rip them off,
just trying to give him something good and people will respond.
And uh,
that is what we've been seeing with Ting.
If you go to rogan.ting.com you can save 25 bucks off of either one of the
android devices or their service.
Um,
I've got a lot of people from Twitter that have contacted me after switching
over to tank and told me how much money they're saving and a,
you know,
like real substantial money.
And people were very happy with the service.
It's on sprint and it's not like it's a small mom and pop cell phone company.
It's on the sprint backbone.
They uh,
they buy time there,
so it's,
it's a really bad ass service.
So please go and check it out.
rogan.ting.com.
Um,
this Wednesday night,
is it Brian?
Thursday night,
Thursday night.
You guys have a desk squad show at the,
uh,
what does that mean?
That's quite show.
It's a comedy show.
Dammit.
This Thursday night at the,
uh,
one of the coolest comedy clubs in the southern California area.
American comedy company in San Diego's.
It's really bad ass low ceiling,
like really set up
cool.
And it's area too.
So like afterwards there's a huge bars across the street and just party at
afterwards.
I've been to San Diego,
you know,
you should go down just to check it out cause it's such a cool little area.
People walk there,
you know,
nobody walks in.
La La is like walk free unless you like,
there's like a couple of blocks on Melrose where you might catch somebody's
walking around.
Right.
But,
uh,
for the most part,
people are not really walking around,
you know,
and their cars.
Yeah.
That's about it.
So,
uh,
it's this Thursday night and the lineup is a Yoshi,
you've heard him on our podcast and she didn't,
no,
she didn't podcast a,
he's also,
a lot of times it's on David chose podcasts.
Very,
very funny guy.
Billy button now.
A very funny guy.
Jason [inaudible] of course,
our buddy we've had him on before.
It's very,
very cool guy and funny guy and Tony Hinchcliffe really hot up and coming comic.
I really believe that Tony Hinchcliffe like five,
six years from now is going to be like,
he's,
he's serious.
Fuck up.
You know what?
I was watching him last night and the most amazing thing about him is how fast
he was.
Like he was doing a,
uh,
Don Barrett's goes,
what do you think the lead singer of counting crows,
is he Jewish or not Jewish?
And Tony Goes,
uh,
Jewish Jewish.
It should be the accounting crows
and it was so fast.
I was like,
how the fuck did you do that that fast?
He's,
he's,
it's hilarious.
He's a very,
very funny guy.
So that's our next Thursday night.
It's Thursday.
I'm sorry.
This as the next one that comes up.
Yeah,
this one,
this one and three days and it's American Comedy code.com for tickets.
We were also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com.
Um,
but one the things you start carrying it.
It's o,
n,
N,
I t.
Um,
one of the things that,
uh,
we started carrying his,
we started carrying these fitness,
uh,
apparatus things like kettlebells and now we've added to them,
we have a,
a mace,
which is this crazy pipe with a metal ball.
It looks like a mapping and a steel club against not a weapon.
Club bells are a very functional way to,
uh,
to get straight,
especially in your shoulders.
They're not even that heavy.
The ones,
uh,
I use you use between like 15 and 25 pounds.
It seems like nothing.
But when you do all these things like they're called shield casts and all these
different exercises with the clubs,
you'd be amazed at how much they wear you out.
Um,
one of the things that on it is interested in,
and then really the only thing we're interested in is things that increase your
physical performance.
Um,
is a lot of people out there doing like bicep curls and doing like traditional
weightlifting exercises and they don't really understand,
uh,
like what,
what you can get some benefit out of any kind of lifting weights,
but to really get the maximum amount of benefit from your time,
you wanted to do something that involves your whole body and you'd be amazed at
what kind of a workout you can get with a 35 pound kettle bell.
I mean,
it is phenomenal.
Me.
You can get it.
I mean,
I'm talking 20 minutes in,
you're ready to die from a 35 pound Kettlebell.
Um,
go to [inaudible] dot com and check out all of the,
um,
all the,
all the fitness equipment.
And I always advise anybody,
if you've been thinking about doing something like that,
get a trainer.
Just hire at least once to have someone show you how to do the proper maneuvers
so you're not,
you use proper technique and not putting a lot of strain on your body.
You really should,
if you can afford it,
get a trainer.
If you can't,
there are some online videos you can get off of youtube that are good,
um,
instructional videos,
but it's very important to start light and use good form.
You can always get injured in lifting weights,
boss route,
and we'll tell you about that later.
Um,
I,
you know,
I've been injured many times exercising.
It's just part of the program.
If you want to get fit,
you have to take chances and if you take chances,
sometimes you get hurt.
But you want to minimize that as much as possible.
And one of the best ways is good form use.
Always use good form.
Never allow yourself to get sloppy when you're training.
And if you feel like you're getting sloppy,
most likely you're using two heavyweight.
Um,
it's just for functional strength.
You really can't beat the stuff that we have at [inaudible] dot com battle
ropes,
kettle bells,
Macy's steel clubs.
We also have a gang of supplements including the famous Alpha brain,
one of the best cognitive enhancing supplement I've ever taken.
It's a,
as far as vitamins go,
not including certain smart drugs that probably will be illegal soon.
But other than that,
Alpha brains is shit.
It's uh,
it's all basically the building blocks for human neurotransmitters.
It's all,
all the essential nutrients that help your mind function at its best.
Um,
there's a lot of controversy when it comes to any of this stuff and that's one
of the reasons why it on it.
We have a 100% money back guarantee on your first order,
30 pills,
whether it's shroom tech or new mood,
which is a serotonin boosting supplement.
You don't,
you don't even have to send the product back.
Just say it doesn't work and you get your money back.
That's how confident we are that we're selling you the very best shit we can
find.
And I say this too much,
but uh,
you know,
it's just,
it's impossible to do a commercial fucking 100,000 times in a row and seems
sincere.
But,
uh,
I am sincere and as is on it,
the,
the companies,
it's a very ethical company and they're cool motherfuckers.
And Use a code name rogue and you'll save 10% off any supplements.
All right,
you fucks boss Rutin is here,
ladies and gentlemen with fin to get crazy.
We're going to get jiggy with it and we're going to,
we're going to learn some knowledge from the great master master route
was in the house
experience.
Powerful boss
roots and welcome to the podcast,
sir.
It's always a pleasure.
Same here.
You know,
I'm,
I'm amazed with the commercials.
You Fox shit mother fuckers,
you know,
that's,
that's great way to,
you know,
get it out there.
Well,
you know what it is,
man,
you gotta be yourself.
You've got to always be yourself,
you know,
and anybody who doesn't want to hear that kind of stuff,
I don't want them less than.
So it's a way of filtering out tight asses.
I don't think that anybody hit the delete button right now.
You never know,
man.
This dude's will get pissed off at anything.
They will decide that your commercial is the reason why their life sucks.
This motherfucker in his audit,
fuck you and fuck on it,
and they'll shoot their fucking computers.
There's someone out there that you're,
you're catching them.
They're there at nine before you even meet them.
Just Eh,
and then they just decide.
It's that fucking boss route and o tube trainer.
Yes.
That sent me over the Tacos that my wife gave it to me just before I walked out
and she says,
you're going to be on camera,
right?
Yeah.
You're that
trainer is a,
it's like for include improving the strength of your lungs.
Is that what it is?
That's it and cool.
Yeah.
We talked about it as much,
you don't know,
boss route and former UFC heavyweight champion.
If you're not into the world of martial arts,
I should always introduce my guests.
I never do.
I just start conversations.
Bosses,
a good friends,
but a good friend for years and one of the,
one of the greatest mixed martial arts fighters in history,
we legit,
you're a,
you're a legend.
Like you know,
you,
when you fought a [inaudible] Osaka,
you know,
that was a,
that was like one of the highest level MMA fights that we had ever seen up to
that day.
You know,
like you,
you,
when you came into the scene,
when you won the heavyweight title,
you elevated the entire sport.
Like you were the fucking man.
Wow.
You know?
No,
no,
I didn't know that.
I do know,
I recently found out that that was actually the first heavyweight champion.
I didn't know that.
Well,
you were actually super fights for you.
Not only that you are,
you were only about 210,
220 pounds at your heaviest.
Right.
I was,
um,
at,
at the fight I was under
210.
It was 200 and over.
I literally had to drink water at the way in to make two or three because
otherwise I said it's not going to be a title fight.
Yeah.
You had to be above the,
the light heavyweight limit was two or three at 1.2,
100,
two or three in Japan.
Right?
Pride.
Yeah.
Call A,
they called it middleweight though.
It's what is that?
That is 93 kilos I believe is two or three.
Yeah.
Or 91.
So you are a small heavyweight man.
You know,
at that time that a and h you could get away with it nowadays,
you know,
I would find it to a five because it's very,
I'm,
I'm already walking around almost the two,
five.
But at that time you fought,
I liked the word heavyweight title much better.
And the world he's made guys,
when you beat up the list,
you know,
the big,
big guy,
uh,
you only had to survive there for like four minutes.
If they brought an onslaught and,
and then,
you know,
it was smooth sailing from there.
You know,
you could,
uh,
where am I done?
Yeah.
To,
to a lot of mixed martial arts fans.
When you look at the,
uh,
the errors of fighting you,
you certainly brought in and the error of the technical striker into the
heavyweight combat sports cause you and Mari Smith will really like the first
guys and of course he's came after you,
but there were the first guys to,
you know,
to really till this,
it's like have like real technical striking,
you know,
not just powerful guys who can knock anybody out because there was always going
to be a lot of those.
But like did you see the Bernard Hopkins fight this weekend?
No,
I did not.
Great fight.
He want again want again.
This guy is unbelievable.
What you can learn.
Like anybody who's like interested in any sort of martial art watching that
Bernard Hopkins files,
she knows really good with that.
Yep.
His technique is perfect.
His defense,
the way he rolls away from shots and even then he occasionally got hit,
but he knows how to cover up.
He knows how to protect himself and that the technical fighters are always going
to have an edge.
It's not easy to be technical.
The instincts that just to go,
ah,
go crazy and attack,
but there's gotta be a method to your madness and that's what separates the men
from the great men,
from,
you know the other fighters.
Well,
you were talking about Barbara Schmidt and I have to tell this really funny
story real fast because I fought him twice actually in,
in pancreas and it was just one time I kicked him in the head and I go,
oh,
this is easy.
I made a switch kick,
but I slipped and I fell on the ground and he wants to jump on top of me and I
go,
wait,
wait.
And he stopped and I get up and I go,
thank you.
It's just that stop.
Yeah.
You told me this before,
that was unbelievably ridiculous.
You hypnotize them.
That's a use Jedi mind tricks.
Timeout.
Wait one second.
You were having some back pains as far back as the [inaudible],
right?
Yeah.
It all started there,
you know,
six weeks before the CACHACA fired,
I had Dell Goler the wrestler and I'm in a triangle choke,
and he thought it was smart to lift me up and slammed me down and he slammed me
with my head against a wall in the corner.
And that really did some damage to me.
You know,
I,
I had a baby at the time,
she couldn't even lay on my chest.
I couldn't breathe,
couldn't cough,
you know,
and I,
I brought that a hole,
that thing with me too.
The Randleman fight as well,
you know.
But you know,
once they put me on the posters and they introduced me like world's greatest
more stores,
I don't know.
I can't say no.
Now I gotta I gotta do this thing,
you know.
So I,
uh,
I remember I was in the dressing room.
I had this big a syringe with Lidocaine and I was injecting myself in between my
ribs.
And then the camera crew came in and they see me and it was at the time,
I believe with universal soldiers and they see me ejecting and they turned
around,
they ran out,
they thought I was doing something illegal.
I said,
dude,
I'm just putting a lot of gain in a year because it was so painful.
So this is when you were about to fight,
you were pumping yourself full with Lidacain?
Yeah.
In between the ribs.
You,
um,
did you ever get an Mri for that?
Find out what that was?
No,
that just,
it just went away after years,
took a long time to sleep,
just,
I took a lot of sleep medication at the time because it would hurt during sleep.
Yeah.
You probably had a bulging disc or something or a herniated,
a lot of policy disco,
you know,
I just had neck surgery two years ago and then I now had it again,
uh,
early this year and now they fused three discs together.
Now was finally like yesterday.
They,
before it started,
I feel slightly slowly lift my arm.
She has a whole dent in here.
Yeah.
See and hear,
it's all gone and it's really weird.
All those muscles,
they have to start refiring so to say.
And so it's cause the nerves were cut off.
They were pinched binders.
Herniation,
yeah.
Lost complete power,
man.
That's a,
it's a scary thing when you can grab the milk out of the fridge anymore,
you know?
And especially if you're used to doing 100 pull ups,
you know,
so,
uh,
yeah,
that,
that kind of scare me.
So,
but now we're,
we're back on track and hopefully it comes back.
So you got three discs fused,
so upper and lower to one,
so it's three in a row,
three in a row,
five,
six and seven.
And um,
is that an issue?
And putting pressure on the discs above it and below it will,
it will happen for especially the one below it,
you know,
that's what they already want me for.
But like my,
my mobility is the same.
I was amazed when I came out because they told me,
you know,
three districts a big deal and,
but I,
I don't feel any different than I was before.
So That's interesting.
Yeah.
So you probably were hindered in your mobility anyway because your disc issue.
That's probably the case.
Yeah.
I'm going through a little bit of a halt.
That's great now too,
but I don't have any numbness or anything,
but I'll be getting it treated.
I've been getting rolfing done and I'm getting spinal decompression and they put
you in a machine and stretch you out
golfing.
Last week I had that down,
but his old lady that comes in and a,
it just kills me.
Terrorized body.
It's amazing.
It's painful,
right?
It is.
And you know when it really fascinating conversation I had with this a woman
yesterday who is a chiropractor who told me you would be surprised,
like people take a anti-inflammatories,
but how much of um,
how much you can do with food just by eating a resveratrol.
I'm cutting out all your wheat and cutting out pasta and gluten and all that
crap.
She's like,
you would,
you would decrease your inflammation so much from all that stuff.
Like we don't understand that we have,
like we have very powerful immune systems for the most part and we're constantly
fighting things off.
But your body is using,
your body is fighting off like inflammation all the time and it's better.
It's better at doing it when it's not being poisoned and when your body doesn't
have wheat to deal with,
like we don't think about it,
but pasta and bread,
all that delicious stuff,
it was fucking terrible for you.
It's like,
it's basically sugar.
It's just as sloppy gooey fucking nonsense that your body's not really supposed
to be eating.
And then she was going on and on about [inaudible] and resveratrol and all these
different uh,
antioxidants and eating a clean,
much more like Paleo Diet.
I'm trying,
I'm trying actually gluten free more now.
More often.
Not completely because as well.
Yeah.
But uh,
you know,
I same breakfast,
a shitty breakfast all the time.
I had this brown rice,
Craig Brown rice with the hot water and honey and I've been eating them for the
last years because he's the only foot I otherwise I don't eat till like four
o'clock.
I am not hungry during the day at force myself to drink this thing.
And then when the in my stomach I get hungry and are now,
actually I just ate a Burrito just before I came here,
which is amazing for me
because normally I never eat.
So you really have been,
is this because of your injury?
No,
no,
no.
I had my whole life had that,
you know,
I will wake up,
same brand and everything with me if it works and never change it.
Like I have to strain,
same stretching routine.
I was talking about it last time,
but I'll share the same food when I think my whole career,
I eight six slices of bread in the morning with like a,
a marmalade jelly on it though because I believe that the peel,
the orange peel,
you know that it,
uh,
stopped lactic acid from getting into your muscles.
And I always had that feeling with it as sometimes I edit peanut butter and that
was my breakfast.
And when I say that,
that means my entire career I would do the same thing and we'll wake up very
early,
two hours before my workout,
eat,
go back to sleep.
And then when I would wake up and will be digested and I was not training.
Wow.
But that's not like what I mean.
Nutritionist would ever tell you no,
no,
no.
The best thing I,
you know Ryan Parson,
she know he was a,
with me with my last fight when I was training together with Kevin,
Kevin,
Jim,
she was there all the time for real because they said,
oh,
it's a publicity stunt.
Him in the corner high.
He was a pretty much every day helping me training,
shouting,
screaming,
and Ryan Parsons where the last fight,
when you see me,
I look the best I've ever looked.
I go,
my God,
you know,
this is,
but it was just because that was the first time in my life.
I had a diet.
I ate like six,
seven times a day.
Small portions,
fish,
chicken,
rice,
all that,
all that stuff that I never did.
I ate pizza and steaks and beer.
You know,
when I was competing,
I,
that just worked for me.
So again,
why would I break a windrow money or why you were in training camp?
Yeah.
I,
you know,
actually in a home in Japan,
you done and stuff.
When you go from Holland to Japan,
there's an a,
an a a time difference,
which is daytime is nighttime for you.
Right?
So that means you're awake all night and around seven o'clock at night in the
morning,
that in becomes 11 o'clock at in your,
where you come
from,
you're going to start falling asleep.
So I go after the first two fights.
I don't want to take sleeping pills because I'm going to compete at the,
I've always figured like a medication slows me down.
And I said,
I always stayed away from that.
But then I say,
you know,
let's go out.
We've got great Rappongi here and we'd drink a couple of beers and it worked,
you know,
I will come home and fall asleep and uh,
that became my,
you know,
how you saying my,
my schedule became your,
before the fight I would just go out and get a couple of beers and then fuck how
many beers?
Three.
Five,
yeah.
Five beers before a fight.
You know your in all of it.
So what you,
you kind of used to that,
you know,
in,
in the evening you're drinking,
you're doing just in the and a what is a Germany?
They actually in the army they drink during the day.
There's people that own the arm.
Yeah.
The LEWITT Lieutenant Society and Shit Explains
Hitler.
They were hammered.
It made sense.
That's hilarious.
So whether they just drink a beer with lunch or something,
I guess.
Yeah.
No they do.
You know,
I was at a training,
a d elite special forces.
They did the same thing during the day they drink beer.
Wow.
That's crazy.
I never would have thought that that would ever happen in the army.
When know some places the,
it's common that you drink wine with lunch.
Like in France.
Yeah.
Ingres I had Larry Papadopoulos with me.
He would,
every morning he had a his port with him and he would drink a glass of port
every morning.
Yeah.
Like a half a glass,
you know,
he said it will fight all the,
what do your immune system,
it's good for that.
And so
he just likes beer.
That mother fucker.
Yeah.
Likes to get a kick in the money.
That's crazy.
So,
um,
that's the,
you've,
we were afraid of sleeping pills,
but you weren't afraid of the repercussions of alcohol?
No.
No,
because it doesn't do anything.
I believe it's natural.
Right.
I wouldn't get tanked,
but I have moments that when I would,
but the stare down and it,
which I never did.
I,
you know,
only when they tried to intimidate me then I will put it on in them,
you know?
But,
uh,
otherwise we'll just look down.
But I,
I,
I knew they would smell like the food is coming from your month ago.
Like,
this guy is crazy.
You know?
I always thought actually,
because at the end they didn't do it anymore because it was finding here in
America and I didn't need it because I'm falling asleep,
but I was thought,
you know,
to go to the,
to be for just before you go to the center of the cage,
flushed with whiskey in your mouth,
spit out to go to him and then let them think that you're hammered,
you know,
just to get inside their heads.
Yeah.
There's some guys that show up in Jujitsu class drunk.
There's this one dude,
he used to be drunk all the time.
We'd roll with them.
You know,
he smelled a whiskey.
Well,
there's a lot of guys stone,
right?
So different though in that stone doesn't fuck with your reflexes.
Not to me.
These,
it doesn't,
does it fuck with my reaction time?
I actually feel like I'm probably better at Jiu Jitsu when I'm high.
I guys feel like that.
That's why so many of them rolls,
roll,
stoned,
you know,
get more creative.
Alter.
I actually come up with more stuff.
Yeah.
More creative,
more relaxed,
more completely focused on what you're doing.
They say that it's easier
to get into it,
you know,
wouldn't,
wouldn't work for me.
I'm a plant,
one of those guys.
If I do it,
I'm sitting in a meeting and there's no,
you ask me two questions.
Hey boss,
what's your,
what's your Christian and everybody Christian names and where you were born.
I go out,
Sebastian and they will all was the other question.
You know,
I,
I literally,
my friends would laugh.
I'd five second memory.
It's amazing.
While everybody's different.
So when you were,
when you were competing,
so no,
we'd even though you live in Holland.
No,
never.
Never.
It was never my daughter.
I smoke weed.
Isn't that funny?
You know it is because it's not,
it's not taboo.
It's not taboo.
You know,
it's like drinking age.
You don't have in holiday,
I think you'd now have,
it's maybe 14 or something,
but you never,
he never had a drinking age.
But all these kids,
they are not going to say,
hey,
I want to drink because it's cool.
You know,
because it is not cool.
And 12 year old and 14 year old kid can do it.
Right.
Yeah.
It's no big deal.
That's just a part of life.
Yeah.
12 year old,
13 year old kid.
Holy Shit.
That's hilarious.
I wasn't,
I was,
I was in America and a half a year and then I went back to Holland to,
to visit the family and it was looking at an a,
they call it the puppet care,
whatever theater.
This is the two,
two little curtains open up and there are people from haulers are everywhere and
from the country and they can say whatever.
Whatever's on their mind.
And there were two little kids sitting there with a,
with a bottle of wine again.
And they said,
yeah,
we like to drink beer.
And they were drinking.
And I look at my wife and I go,
Ooh,
matches.
This happens in America where people are going to say it's insane.
I mean,
there were six or eight years old and they were drinking a beer.
Yeah.
My parents,
you know,
order not really against it.
I go,
Whoa,
dude.
And then the curtain closed again.
It was the wireless thing.
Imagine at Strip clubs and the girls are wearing bibs.
Well,
they don't have strip clubs.
They have whorehouses.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean,
Holland is a totally different thing to have a whole area where it's all whore,
whore.
Whorehouses right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The Red Light district,
hey,
yes.
That pretty much every town you have,
the red led to stick,
not only in Amsterdam.
I mean,
think about that for a second.
Not a whorehouse.
No.
A whore neighborhood.
They got a whole hoard neighborhood.
Yeah.
Windowshopping incidences of HIV and all of Europe and Lois,
incidents of heroin addiction,
which is really crazy.
They all get tested.
They all need to be legal there.
There's a lot of testing.
They're going,
yeah.
You know,
and you'll be amazed.
You walk there like if the red,
the red light district in Amsterdam and you see girls that you go like,
you know,
there could be the girl next door.
It's amazing.
The amount of different plethora as though about Berwyn say oh girls that they
have and it's not the s w they wouldn't even think about it the same way we
think about it.
Like the,
the way life is there from the get go is so much different than the way life is
here.
That in my opinion,
like to,
to,
to change our laws and to make it so that prostitution's legal and make some
marijuana just openly tolerated everywhere.
And kids can drink at 12 like,
man,
you would almost have to start from scratch.
Yeah.
You have to.
It's a,
and it's a Ma,
like I couldn't do it.
If you go to the red light districts,
sometimes you see like eight guys in a row waiting in front of one SPEC windows.
She's hot.
Fucking imagine the guy comes out,
he is,
he like an ugly dude giving get it done.
Then you get to go in,
you know,
it's not for me,
it's like don't get Sushi on Sundays and go to a Korean spa at nine o'clock at
night.
It's a Bra.
Yeah,
it seems like Holland.
It's all it all just more laid back.
More fun.
Wilder people.
Right?
Like big,
big kickboxing scene.
Huge kickboxing scene.
You know,
I was,
I was just watching today on Facebook.
Somebody posted the Magiro gym on my Facebook from 83 there was,
when Andre Barilla Mun,
we're still alive.
You know the guy who got killed and tortured.
There's a big story and hall.
It was a phenomenal kickbox.
And you,
so rob came on mil of oil globally.
I mean,
Fred royals,
the eight guys from that gym roll world champions.
I mean they went to Thailand,
beat the thighs.
It wasn't saying.
I went to a show at the op Ada Holland Holland where there were four world title
fights and they broadcast it a life to Thailand and the best Thai boxers came
down and there was like [inaudible] and core.
Rob came and all these guys and we won four out of four.
They're not these guys out.
It was the craziest thing.
It never happened after that again.
Well the Dutch style incorporated a lot more striking with the hands.
Right.
It's a lot more boxing technique.
That's it.
Tie again tying it together.
That's I think the biggest and it has great hands.
Everybody has great hands there and the,
the Dutch style of a striking is really like to the lay person.
It looks like you just kicking and punching,
but the,
the,
the technical aspects of it,
like I've taken some classes with rob came in before,
the way he breaks things down in there,
like patterns and how to follow these paths.
He's got like these automatic patterns that he does.
Like when your foot is here,
he's doing this.
When his arm is here,
he's doing that.
He hits with the left hook and then it's the right leg kick and he's got like
this,
you know,
this really technical system that when you seem sparring,
it's really fascinating to watch it in action.
Yeah,
because he just taught himself to do it all the time.
Like when I,
when I hold focus Mitts for my guys,
I have shin pads on myself and out of the blue I kick and I'll do an admit
combination.
Whenever they don't expect it and they got whatever left Geeky counters with the
cross hook,
locate any other kind of who cross low kick,
you know?
And then we changed the combination,
right buddy,
left hook,
low kick or you know,
or left hook,
right body,
you know,
and liver shot.
Right?
I mean ideas but it's all the time them into the head.
So that in combat at all comes out,
oh automatically here tech come should bump up their show character and whether
you,
it's gotta be a started with a body shot and then a hat or a head body or had
had a buddy buddy,
whatever it is.
That's what people really truly don't understand about.
Um,
about the,
what,
it's what's required in order to pull something off under extreme stress.
Yep.
You know,
we had Sam Sheridan,
he's uh,
he wrote that book of fighter's mind.
If I just have somebody recently talk to me about it,
you have very good book actually.
Great.
He,
and he's got a great new one out called the disaster diaries and it's all
about pressure in dealing with natural disaster is horrible situations where
people's character gets exposed and how to stay calm.
And one of the things he's talking about in the book is about like what,
what,
how your body moves in,
in a competition and that you,
the only things that are going to come out,
are there things that you've drilled into your brain to the point where they're
in your subconscious.
So like the,
the left Hook whizzes by your head.
The counters right there,
it's just automatic.
It has to be automatic because you're not going to have time to think and you're
going to be flooded with adrenaline.
I had an a,
a guy who came to me,
he actually won the amateur title last weekend to Yens Growl.
He was 38 years old when he came to me.
It was 245 pounds as a power lifter,
and he wanted to train.
He had to,
he had a torn bicep yet,
this big bar sticking out of his arm,
and he said,
well,
when do you want to trade?
He said,
tomorrow.
So I grabbed him by the bar and I pulled him to the side and I say,
now really working,
right then he goes,
yeah,
I didn't know,
but maybe we can start with kicks.
I said,
first of all,
we got to lose that weight.
I mean,
this is going to stop you.
You can't even scratch your back.
And he started training,
training,
and every time he would ask me,
boss,
when you were on the ground and your site much,
you teach us Denise to the thighs,
right?
Yeah.
That's allowed,
right?
Yeah.
What?
Why?
It's not been anybody doing it.
I said,
because they're still,
but they don't do that.
I said,
why wait till you're fighting?
And then another Chi Asian in a clean,
she know you can hit the tie stall or elbowed him and yeah,
why is nobody doing it now or wait until you're fighting,
you'll find out when you're fighting.
And every week he came back with another question.
I say,
just wait.
Now I had a few combinations.
I have combinations.
I give you like three combinations,
standup attack combinations,
three up against a wall and an underground.
Some.
So there's only six you get.
But when they come back at you,
almost a guarantee they're going to knock you out.
You know,
they're just really solid combination.
So one of them was an a big hoop net to the spleen,
but you keep your whole demeanor low and while you,
and then you're hitting high,
but everything stays low.
So he thinks it's not a buddy shot now to fight started.
It was amateur,
so it was,
it was all over the place and nothing,
oh my God.
And his hands went up.
But the one thing came back and was the right hook to the body right into it.
Then that's how we knocked about and you see and there you see like even in all
that chaos,
because I always know that people,
when when I knocked out my first Tai boxer,
if they would at the moment of knockout,
it would a blind folded me.
They would've called him 500 guys and then they put my blind full of say,
okay,
who?
Who did you fight?
I had no clue who I fought it.
It's like the,
it's a person but you can't judge doesn't have a face.
It's like Eh,
you know,
there's too much going on.
It's like the first night driving a car,
but once you can channel all that,
he knows to listen to their corner and doing that stuff,
then it comes together.
But at the end it's all panic.
One combination came back and it happened to knock them out.
You wouldn't,
why?
How do the Dutch figured that out?
How'd the Dutch figure out to add the hand combinations and the boxing
combinations?
Because the ties were already using their hands but much less so than they were
using their legs.
I have no clue.
I,
I think just the size of their daddies.
Yeah.
I don't,
I think just,
uh,
it automatically came with him,
you know,
[inaudible] I truly believe it really started at Magiro gym there,
then in which Bob Caymen,
so all those guys there,
you know,
and then a Shucker rekey all although Shams manhole,
of core hammers and everybody started coming.
I recently saw a video from a Roman records when he was 19 years old,
you know,
and that was at the time when,
the first time when I saw him destroying somebody's,
my buddy told me,
he says,
watch this man.
You're going to freak out.
And I thought he's going to get killed this kid.
But he just drilled,
he gave him a low kick and the guy flies horizontal in the air and he falls.
And I was like,
what?
I mean,
you got to see pictures of him when he was giddy.
Yeah.
Ramon Dekkers unfortunately just passed away,
I think two weeks ago.
Right.
You had a 27.
Now.
He had,
apparently it had a heart attack while he was riding his bike.
Um,
he was amazing.
Amazing guy to watch and you could watch the older fights and then the newer
fights,
as you know,
he got older,
he got thicker,
more muscular.
But you're right.
In the early days when he first started finding these very,
very thin,
he was the,
he was the eye every interview for 25 years.
I've been saying it,
you know,
the best striker,
Emma May bloodline,
she teachers company that wants to do something with me and I'm over them or may
have a whole show with kickboxing.
And I say no,
you know,
from Holland,
you know the,
that,
that you got to go to a Ramon Dekkers Peter,
it's an as to host.
That's not me.
You know,
I'm did Emmi because these guys are just really good,
you know,
and I,
and my whole style was pretty much what decker did.
And I,
I took that and I took Mike Tyson,
you know,
because he's the most powerful striker and I that my whole style like that
square up set up square,
oh you gotta be a smaller target.
All these people,
you're not going to do some apps do it.
I mean,
uh,
that,
that will stop you from body shots.
The Tyson never go down to his buddy.
No,
he did not,
you know,
and he fought against the best people in the world,
but he knocks people out with a jab because it's not a jap anymore.
It's a straight punch at the moment when you square up,
you know,
and uh,
and that's why I believe that.
But it was Mike that was Decker's was included in that decker squared up with
God's also,
but not as much,
but he didn't know.
Yeah.
Also have to sprawl.
That was a,
that was a big difference.
Right.
This shifting like watching Bernard Hopkins this weekend,
I mean,
he stands totally sideways box.
Unbelievable.
And you can't do that in MMA.
It's too easy to take you down.
Yup.
And leg kicks to.
Yeah.
But yeah,
also,
yeah,
but also,
I cannot imagine,
you know,
Duane Ludwig when he knocked out Deon spillover,
we knew what the answer was going to do,
but he spent all the way in one line.
He's a South Pole.
If he wants to throw a left of a right hook,
he has to load up.
So we thought if you write straight,
that's it.
Right.
And you can watch the fight at the moment.
He doesn't once and drained it and she,
and do you see Dwayne looking at me like damn,
I missed that one.
But right away he does it again.
And Dwayne Nielsen right away with a straight punch.
Well it's still does.
How's this vicious technical right hand too?
You know the way he throws it and it's like it's so crisp and that's how he got
it.
The fastest knockout ever in the
UFC history.
It's is one of those guys that I have no clue.
It was just talking to my buddy about it.
It's like this guy is the nicest guy.
Does everything right as do drugs,
isn't drank,
does it?
She knows that Colleen has guy out there for some reason,
he always has these crazy injuries like you misstep and he breaks his ankle or
pull out his knee.
And I always go,
why is that?
You know,
such a good guy deserve so much better.
It's physical.
It's just,
you know,
it's life.
You know,
you only got so many miles you could put on that car.
That's true.
After awhile,
ball joints start braking.
It's a crazy thing when you think about Duane had so many fights,
you know,
before he even got to the UFC,
he had a so many king of the cage fights and you know,
he had kickboxing bouts.
You know,
he won a world title and Moy talk,
right?
Yes he did.
Yeah.
So that's a lot of wear and tear.
A lot of wear and tear on your body.
You know,
I show,
I saw Dwayne first time when I did the bus routes.
Amputation.
You're like,
she had a lot of fighters.
Uh,
nowadays she'll became bigger fighters come from that.
A tournament that we had.
And it was so bad as that one mode.
You had to fight four times in one night and it was almost no weight classes.
And they do that recently to glory is a long time.
Yeah.
Uh,
Gloria does.
It's striking,
but he,
that's where I found Dwayne for the first time he was there and we needed an
opponent for somebody and a GSL.
I'll do it.
And this little kid jumps up and he finds this guy 30 pound heavier.
Noxzema woulda had cake.
And I go,
Ooh,
I got to know this kid is,
and then we became friends instantly there.
Yeah.
Dwayne has been around very,
very nice guy.
And now he's the head trainer at a Alpha male.
Yeah.
That's great.
How cool is that?
He did.
Was teaching a seminar there.
I love watching guys like you move into a commentating careers too.
Yup.
You A,
your host MMA live now,
right?
What is it inside of them?
Inside of my main,
what does that,
my main lives that even exist in anymore?
I don't know all these different fucking names.
The porn thing is,
it's on access TV.
It's you and Kenny rice and guests always.
And uh,
he'd been doing it a long time now.
Shake.
She has man.
It's a crazy,
yeah.
Every wig gets a great gig.
It is.
This is the Gig that salt,
uh,
pulled me out of all the stress,
you know,
I was people,
I have no clue what I had to do to stay here,
to survive with,
for my family.
You know,
the first nine years I missed every Christmas,
every new year because I was in Japan doing those big shows.
You know,
I missed the holidays,
birthdays,
I missed the birth of my youngest daughter.
I mean a whole because I had to go otherwise there was no more money.
We give people think when you're on TV,
but the paper view Uri,
he's rich.
It doesn't work like that,
you know?
And,
and I had to come back and right away I had to do a seminar here and the seminar
there,
and constant traveling constantly.
And then when inside of a May came along,
you know,
they gave me the basic income and that was the first time in my 11.
Now I actually have the power to say no,
you know,
and now it's an actually,
financially he's also much better because now they're going to,
if you say no,
this hell,
I'll double it.
No,
no,
I really know it.
Oh,
what about we triple it?
You see
it's,
but I didn't have that power all the way back and now for me,
if it really doesn't interest me,
I'd rather stay with the family.
You know what?
I missed enough.
I'm trying to catch up now and see if I can do that.
Yeah,
that's a tough thing.
You are the commentator,
the head commentary and pride and you were constantly going back and forth for
that.
How many fights did you go over there to cover?
12 year because you have Bushido at her one time.
Also I 12 a year when I became citizen here,
right.
I had to count how many times I left the country and I had a passport and I go,
my God,
this is an insane number.
So I went to my old passport and I started counting 152 times I've been to
Japan,
but that's Holland and an America.
Is that crazy?
I mean we're talking about that.
That's a three year solid straight because every time it was at least average a
week because sometimes it was four days but many times a week or or or I say
sometimes even for three weeks to train there because I had no training partners
in the holidays.
You are still thinking about finding back then to whatever kept you from
fighting in pride because I was Ruben Warpath I was going to come back.
I was going to come back when uh,
you know I had many injuries.
I started really because all the injuries tend to night is I had,
I think it comes from all the cortisone I took when I was a kid and that started
really to flaring up and once that starts,
man,
it's training till the fight is going to be nightmare.
You have about 45 minutes to train without it and then it will hit you,
you,
you know as much about stop training because everything will go downhill from
there and then you're in pain for an hour and a half intense.
It's like really intense pain and you know,
it sucks the life out of me.
And not happy anymore.
And I didn't want to train and I couldn't eat because of the pain.
Wow.
This tendonitis is,
you believe it's from cortisone shots.
I took way too many conditions when I was a kid because I was so sick,
you know,
at a,
but anyway,
then when I started recently training a little bit and just striking,
you know,
I tried to stay away from grappling because if I have to power out or something
then it would hit again.
And then,
um,
when,
Ken shamrock came,
I said,
listen,
I want to be first fight.
You know,
I come out of retirement for him.
I want to,
I'm going to find him.
But he declined.
He said,
no,
we already did it.
We don't need to do it again.
So,
but that was the,
I was going to fight for the fight.
And then it was almost happened with Vandelay at the dynamite show because there
was a mix between k one and an h and m and mixed martial arts,
a pride.
And um,
I said they looking for an opponent for ventilator.
I said,
oh,
I'll fire him.
I said,
what,
what are we doing on a rule on this?
And I haven't been ground fighting for three years.
What about this?
People want to see this.
Anyway,
we'll put on the PRI gloves and we do k one rules.
You know,
I think that's what people would love to see.
Right.
And then also,
I didn't happen at last segment and it was not because of that would have been
great,
I think,
because at that time almost,
I pretty a shake a shape.
I started kicking a Amir's type ads and he,
his whole arms were bruised up the next day he goes,
I think you already said.
So,
uh,
I felt good.
Ah,
that would have been an amazing to say,
Holy Shit.
I still,
till this day I always say,
why isn't there a company that comes out with that idea that I just said they
did cage combat.
It's gone,
but yeah.
Yeah.
And uh,
what is his name?
John Wayne Parks Australia.
Do you know who he is?
I heard about a bad ass.
Kickbox are very,
very good.
Kickboxer that's fun.
Yeah.
And he's uh,
he's calling it,
I think it's called caged Moyie Thai or something like that.
Let me,
let me find out how many minutes.
Like 500 bucks as well.
They do it like for three minute rounds.
Sandwich,
cable and done.
Yeah.
I think that's how they're doing it.
Um,
let me find this,
cause I know there were,
uh,
he's a,
he's a good dude too.
I want to get PC though.
That's exciting.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Watch out.
Yeah,
it's,
it is interesting,
isn't it?
That uh,
they other strikers striking sports never switched it.
A little gloves.
I never tried the little gloves.
It's amazing.
It's amazing because now we realize that it doesn't really,
you know,
it's not really any difference I guess.
But the impact,
I think only body shots maybe because it's a smaller surface,
it penetrates to easier I think,
but I don't think that the had,
you know,
even with a bare knuckle hitting your head or with the glove.
But if I have to say,
I do think that with the glove has more impact.
People don't understand that bare knuckle,
bare knuckle,
you could really hurt yourself.
Also punching some hardheaded dude in the forehead.
Oh,
that's what I used to do when it was a bounce.
Also,
I was at,
look at it,
my fellow bonuses,
I say,
check this out.
There's somebody who was angry.
I let her throw a punch and I just leaned forward to hit the top of my head,
you know,
and uh,
it's a fun way to pull a trick on somebody because they,
they hit you once.
Yeah.
Once.
So John Wayne Pars Company's called Caged Moy Tai and uh,
it is,
uh,
it is essentially that it's a movie tie in a cage.
Ever make left a,
I'm going to make gloves.
I believe at something like gloves 11.
It looks like him on my gloves.
Yeah.
Um,
the,
there's a difference in the way you can defend yourself too with those boxing
gloves.
A big difference.
You know,
it used to cover yourself up,
you cover so much more area and then they glove goes right behind it right
through the middle.
Yeah.
Interesting.
Especially buddy shots also.
Yeah.
Right.
You really can dig in with,
Oh,
I shot.
It's not a blunt object,
it's sharp.
That's why finally we see guys,
you know,
doing it.
I always talk about the,
I never get it.
I always tell my students,
I say fighting is really easy,
right?
You hit somebody really hunting ahead.
Defense will go up and there's the buddy for you or you do it the other way
around.
Like forming that.
If the body real hot until they have to defend it and then you go on top.
Now when you rock somebody,
step back,
what is he going to defend when you hit somebody at the under chin?
Well he's going to defend his hat.
Why on earth would you start hitting the hat now this is your mom to go to the
body but hit it hard.
Cross who cross to the body.
You know,
combinations like that hit as hard as she can.
That defense has to come down and then you go back to the head and they planted
themselves,
need attack the legs.
But I mean there's only,
there's a few fighters out there.
The last one I saw using it was Rory macdonald against Bj Penn who dropped him
with a body shot or your window not dropping,
but he was hurt and right away he went back to the head,
you know,
and that's,
get them into comfort zone again to bring the hands up and then go for the buddy
again.
You see in that kit that I say,
oh is she now he's thinking,
well,
he's one of those new Rory Macdonald's,
one of those new breed of guys that is getting great at everything.
He doesn't just have one specialty like a wrestler who learned some ground and
pound.
Now he's a,
he's essentially mixed martial artists from the jump and so it was very
technical and in all aspects of his attack.
But you're right in the striking,
we're just sort of starting to see people who have a more nuanced understanding
of different kicks.
You know,
like how about front kicks?
All of a sudden people land in front kicks to the face.
Yep.
Yeah.
Never happened.
That did not.
All the fights we've seen and how you guys got knocked out with a front kick to
the face.
I did not give up but I,
I kicked him under his nose and a frank shamrock.
It's a front kick to know,
say you had a shoe on too.
He smelled that
pancreas was a weird thing.
If anybody who has never seen it before,
they wore shoes and then shin guards over the shoes and you couldn't punch to
the face.
He had a slap open hand.
Yup.
But boss was the only one to figure out that instead of slapping,
use punch combinations.
But just pull the hand way back and,
and you know,
you're essentially blast them with the palm.
And in a way it's even better because you can't break your hand.
You know,
I,
until this day I still don't get it that people don't use it because I always
say it's very simple.
If I'm standing here,
this is the target,
a left hook right straight.
If I conduct with the connect with the left took up to close from my ride
straight,
it doesn't have power.
It needs,
it needs space to do get power to,
to,
to get,
pick up speed so to say.
Right.
But if I do a palm strike and I,
but I do it.
Yeah you see it already but I pull all the way back.
I hit with this bony part here and I hit under air just here underneath the air,
but now the straight punch is way better lined up.
Then they'll have to have bright,
strange combination.
I don't get it.
I get it across Hook because with the cross you bring the head backwards and the
hook,
we'll catch it,
but it have to look right straight.
I say use a palm strike and it says still till this day they don't do it.
It's essentially a bitch slap right hand combination.
That's it.
That's what it is.
Maybe they don't do it because of that.
They think,
you know,
but how cool is,
I believe slept on the couch and today you have to keep your hands close to you.
You can't,
you're not supposed to strike with your hands open.
I mean,
I guess you could probably get away with a karate chop or something like that,
but the issue is going forward and poking eyes.
We have a real problem with a I Pogues.
Wow.
You're a guy had been around a long time and you fought,
you know,
the bare knuckle days did,
did,
was there as many I pokes back then as there are now.
You don't know
what really messed me up as the pro wrestling I started doing after,
after my chemo was over and I started,
you know,
I felt that I could do something again and uh,
he asked me to do pro wrestling.
My first fight,
I break a disc in my back and then the second one I rupture my eyeball with a
finger in my eye because she don't block the punch.
She let him hit you.
And a third almost.
Oh yeah.
An eardrum that's been broke for six years straight because I,
because you fly,
you can't fix it because you,
you cannot fly for six weeks when to do it.
Actually,
it is a funny story.
My first pro wrestling match was with Don Frye was in my corner.
I was fighting this guy and he knew she my or something and was at the Tokyo
Dome,
right to so 60,000 people.
And uh,
you,
you go through a,
you know,
and uh,
this is what you do in the beginning.
Then you ad Lib a little bit and then in the middle of you do this and they ad
lib some morning and the edge,
you know,
you got the,
of the orchestrated progresses.
Yeah.
Pro.
Yeah,
real promising.
And um,
it,
it was gonna he was gonna at the start,
he was going to pick me up,
throw me in the corner and gave me like three elbows in the face and then he
would go to the,
to the audience like woo.
And he would drop me with an elbow.
I will take an eight count,
you know,
and then I would start,
but I'd never progressed in my life before.
So he attacks me and the first Albo he gives and he's perfectly timed.
But the second one is a little harder and the third one hits me full.
And my automatic reflex kicks in and I go boom.
And I hit him in the face and he goes,
Ooh.
And he's out.
So I look at Don and he goes,
and I go,
no.
And the referee,
he's walking around with a guy and he goes,
Juan.
And he walks around too and just start dragging the time,
you know?
Hey,
yeah.
He started twitching and he started waking up,
you know the dog for a moment.
He goes like,
dude,
that was crazy.
I say he hit me hard.
So then the next time,
so did you,
did the guy get up and finish the and he finished the match so it almost
unconscious gushers oh,
he was with his eyes open.
It was when you wake him up,
what do you tell him?
No,
nothing.
Afterwards.
Everybody got scared.
So they came to me.
The second one,
he goes,
please put down no real fight.
I said,
you don't hit me.
I know have to hit you.
It's very simple.
You know,
he hit me hard,
you know?
That's why right.
He took advantage of you,
I guess.
I don't know.
Maybe it was on purpose.
Maybe not,
but uh,
but there wasn't as many.
I pokes back there and then them,
no,
none of them are mine.
Is that,
why do you think that's happening so much?
I never hit like this,
but I'm going to hands and I would all the way pulled back.
I never touched.
You know,
I think it's also a lot of guys who have no a good control and you know,
if they,
I mean to,
I poke somebody,
I'm,
I cannot even imagine that I would never happen with me.
Well there'll be polishing off.
That's what everyone is doing.
Well they got that because you know,
you had,
you know,
you were fighting over the hands open and you weren't poking guy's eyes.
That's what I mean.
You know,
and I never impact course.
I never took a big,
big issue.
Now to the point where it's almost,
it looks like it's on purpose.
Sometimes you know,
you're going to really do it.
I would hate to speculate,
but it's a very unfortunate aspect of having the ability to have open fingers.
And I was wondering if you think there would could be a way we could cover over
the tips with like maybe a soft leather.
So it was all like one smooth piece over the top,
but it was soft enough so that he could still grapple because most people don't
understand.
You don't really grapple like that anyway.
No,
you use your whole hand and the only time you eat the thumb even is involved is
with the risk control.
I mean most of the time when I'm grabbing things,
I'm grabbing things like this cause I,
I'm pulling with my thumb.
I give myself the added muscle down with my thumb.
Whereas you don't have that if you do.
Not only that,
this situation,
for instance,
when somebody has a mountain,
me and a and then never get this anyway,
uh,
people that amount,
they let themselves just buck up.
I always say it's so simple.
I mean just fricking buck up.
You don't bring your feet close to your bus.
Stop bucking up.
He needs to look for balance.
Right.
I guess keep hitting you now at the moment he looks for Bella should catch one
hand and then it's what I always say to my students,
these two fingers had a strongest.
So what I do,
I grab two and two because that's a stronger grip around the wrist.
Then when I do this,
see she might,
and she does the carpal tunnel as sometimes I could.
Uh,
I that comes with the neck is the worst.
Say this,
these three,
three fingers on each hand.
On,
on one wrist.
Yeah,
a goal route on the wrist and a and a bullet to one side.
I look up the foot and I throw him to the other side.
It's sort of easy,
simple reversal.
This,
the grabbing like this is stronger than grabbing them.
Yeah,
because she looked,
this hand is here and the other end the had,
look how open your grip becomes because of the forearm.
But if you have around two fingers here and the attitude fingers there,
you got a really strong grip on one hand,
even when you're on the bottom and he hits you with the other head.
I see what you're saying.
For folks that don't know what the fuck you're talking about,
but what he's saying is that w at the,
the base of the wrist,
it's the thinnest.
So the more strength you have,
more strength in your hands when your fingers are completely wrapped around
something and the finger and the index finger and the thumb are touching
together and the more your fingers are spread out,
the less power you have to grab ahold of something.
So in that,
in the case of the human body,
you're better off grabbing the wrist with three fingers and three fingers.
That was a very wise,
yeah,
that's,
that's very,
very smart.
And so that's what you would do and then fight for a to try to get out of the
mouth,
you know?
Yeah,
because it's,
it's pretty easy once first of all,
mount never allowed him to sit on your chest.
That's a bad mom because then you can buck up whatever you want.
There is no leverage,
you know,
so he doesn't move.
So the first thing,
but I always say,
keep your elbows here always.
Plus if he's already a high chest,
I pushed my elbow share and our wiggle myself upward.
She don't have to push him down,
but you can push yourself up or it's because the end result is the same right
now.
Once he's on your belly,
the other great thing that comes with it is that his feet are underneath your
leg,
so now with your other foot you can catch one of those feet.
You can go listen to this right now going,
what the fuck is he talking about?
He
can,
you can get,
yeah,
so I can catch one of his feet here and then if I grabbed his right arm and I
pull this to the side and at the moment I have it here,
I look at and I'll pull them to that side.
I take this base.
It was really good guys.
Yeah,
it works.
Really good guy.
Who's the best guy you ever pull that off on in training?
That's the whole thing.
I don't know.
When someone tells me like someone in the budget or a new technique,
I'm like,
hmm,
revolutionary technique.
I just take your post and your post away.
It's a very nice,
uh,
basically think,
I think I had to maybe college Newton with it.
Get your shit over at the time,
you know,
because I've been using that a lot.
You know if you,
if you're mounting,
you put an arm around my neck,
you're on your back.
I guarantee you that.
I'll go real fast.
I wait for those moments.
I extended,
I go lay like this.
That means please take my neck.
Man.
When you first started,
you weren't a submission guy at all.
You were mostly just a standup guy,
right?
When you first started competing in pancreas and then what was it like?
Which fight was it?
The really major realize that they can share shamrock last one put me in a knee
bar.
I trained four weeks to not get caught in a knee bar for knock.
He taught me one way to stop it.
He said,
[inaudible] God,
he's going to slip over your hip and you see me in the fight waiting for him to
slip over my hip to catch the foot.
And he threw the leg over my head and I go,
mother,
you know he,
he,
they,
they sent me up with,
but that moment on I said,
okay,
this won't ever happen again.
Now I'm going to listen to people,
but I'm also going to find out if it's really that right way.
And then I started just breaking down everything.
I found one sparring partner,
Leo van Dyke and we went nuts.
We went three times a day.
We are rolling,
rolling,
rolling.
Watching on the fights.
See a move.
Go.
Okay.
How do you get out while I can do this?
How can I stop that?
Oh,
you do the agile breaking down,
breaking down,
breaking essentially taught yourself a little bit of instruction from other
people and a lot of it from tape and trial and error.
Yeah,
just like that.
You know,
I had my big DVDs of combat,
right?
I had a phone call a long time ago this before I knew Bj Penn personally,
and he said,
um,
uh,
hey bosses,
Bj [inaudible] Japan.
Yeah.
Hey,
how are you doing?
Yeah,
I'm getting ready for a runner.
It was [inaudible] was fighting against him.
Uh,
I said,
why are you calling?
He says,
I'm watching you.
Instructionals and I say,
so he says,
the best instructor I've ever seen in my life,
I go,
you're kidding me.
And he says,
yeah,
I gotta go.
We gotta go.
Hey,
can I use that quote?
Because that's a great quote,
but he was also a mess with,
I do a lot of hand control.
My arm bars are different.
My way of breaking your grip.
If I break your grip,
you'll never escape.
I guarantee you that if you break my grip,
I already set myself up.
If my legs are locked,
my elbows right away here and at the moment they stop bulling.
I throw my other legs in the same line as you and I have to make it really tiny
role.
The folks listening to this,
this is all very baffling,
but it's very exciting because there's a bunch of different branches of
grappling in MMA.
You know,
there's like the catch wrassling sort branch where
you know a lot of gene labelle taught guys and a lot like Josh Barnett as well,
very catch wrestling oriented,
oriented and of course is a Brazilian jujitsu oriented.
But there's also like the Japanese style,
which was sort of a combination of the both like Sakuraba who had a lot of Karl
gotch influence who's like one of the early,
uh,
catch wrestling guys to go over to Japan and teach these guys all these
different techniques.
But he also had the Japanese martial arts and you know,
and the,
the,
the judo a submissions and everything as well.
Really fascinating.
Uh,
when,
when you stop and think about when you started,
I mean the first UFC fight was in 93.
When was your first pancreas fight?
93 yeah,
so two months before,
a month before September.
You were there in the beginning of the blossom.
You know,
it must be really interesting to see all these new techniques.
And all these walls and really a lot of ancient techniques,
but become mainstream in new,
what I love about [inaudible],
and this is something I figured out all show like in the early days because
she's like,
I always say an example is the simple figure for everybody knows if they get
four,
right.
I said,
but if you can create a way,
you seem to like an Americana Americana.
I called her figure for reverse takeover.
So if a hammerlock I mean,
just so many names.
That's why I,
yeah.
Um,
uh,
also they always forget to push the arm down now.
Certainly,
but I mean,
you know,
she'll hear you.
You can't do it.
You push it down.
Come on dude.
You have to know this is your
folks listening.
There's a technique.
It's like,
you know,
when a guy's like showing you his muscle,
like you look at my bicep,
boom.
Well that if you take that arm and just drop it down to the ribs and then pull
the arm backwards,
this is surprisingly small amount of room that you can move where you're in
excruciating pain.
But if you keep it up there where you show like the muscle,
you can move way back.
People roll out.
Did they ask you to submit shirts?
But you can get out of it.
But,
but what I always say is everybody knows it's probably the first submission
they'd been taught.
But if you can create different ways to go that submit to set test submission
show,
it's undetected,
it's like the right straight to the face,
you know it's going to come.
But if I find a way to bring to deliver it undetected and that's cancer,
same for a forum submissions.
And that's why I always found two or three or sometimes four,
sorry,
four different ways to go to one combination.
And when I start mixing those up also I go from one to four,
then I go for two to four,
you know,
then you know,
eventually you catch somebody in a,
a guy was really good with that also is no guarantee in the early days,
you know,
he's got triangle armbar old plotter and a constantly pop up,
up,
up cost.
You aren't,
you know,
and,
and that's what I like,
you know,
find different ways.
And that's the coolest one.
I see nowadays.
You see guys get so creative,
suddenly there's a submission and I go walk by,
rewind,
they go,
how the hell did he said that?
And then you know,
and that's something I really enjoy watching,
you know,
when I can't see it coming.
Then I got like okay is,
that's really
cool.
Now when,
what do you miss about pride?
Do you miss anything about the rules?
Cause there's like a lot of debate about like whether or not the pride rules
where the best rules.
A lot of people think that they favored the more skillful fighter and they were
more chaotic because they had stopped soccer kicks,
but yet no elbows.
You know,
I always said elbows and now you know,
now we see guys start knocking people out with them.
But normally if a fight's get stopped by elbows,
95% is because of a cut.
No,
because of a knockout.
So,
and then I say that is not a real win.
If you think about it under the street,
if you get caught,
you won't stop by,
you know,
you keep on fighting.
It's not,
the cut's not going to do anything to you knocking them out.
And that's why I say no.
Sometimes I like it even better and east of the phase on the ground and take the
elbows out for eye care,
you know?
And I think the ring makes it also a little bit more technical because you can't
walk out,
you know,
just,
it's a whole different strategy.
Suddenly you can luck.
Some people are standing,
you can lock them up in the corner.
You can do that in a cage.
It see it.
So this is the,
it's a whole different strategy.
Yeah.
You can't use the cage to push your back against it to get away.
You can't reverse people as easily.
There's a lot the wall,
I mean the cage is almost like a knife,
a weapon in there.
It's almost like a tool.
And now,
especially now we see pat us,
you know,
coming up with the crazy stuff,
pushing off with a straight bar.
Is that one I did,
but that cake,
that was,
that was really crazy actually,
that pushing off and then a within a knee.
Oh,
the trainer from Gilbert.
I IFL all the way back.
Lucian Lucian Carbine.
He used to do that on the bottom rope and Thai boxing and decline.
She would stomp on the bottom rope and I'm hoping he did the face.
Did you see um,
uh,
Anthony Pettis has started throwing knees that way.
How cool.
And how did he slipped it around housing the inventory.
That defense is crazy.
Yeah.
He's got a great time of the fucker.
Yes.
He's,
I mean,
cause Donald Cowboy Cerrone is a bad motherfucker too.
And when he stopped him with a body shot and you could see cowboy didn't want to
acknowledge it,
he blasted him once with a kick to the body.
And all you saw was cowboys APP.
Just thanks for the plug by the way.
I [inaudible] it's a liver shot like boss route knows the power of the liver
shot and he's,
you know,
from bosses commentary,
you've always been so adamant about,
you know,
attacking the liver folks who don't know on your person when he hit you with a
left hook,
there's an area where your liver is where if you take a sizable impact on that
liver,
your body just shuts down and it's,
it's a weird thing to watch.
It's a weird thing to feel,
you know,
everybody's felt that everybody who's ever trained is Felton.
My first Thai boxing class,
I got drunk to deliver shot.
That's where my love comes from.
Delivering shunt.
I was underground breathing and asking him what essay says that I left hook to
the buddy.
That's where your liver is.
Look at it and go,
oh man.
And then
it's when I started focusing because I knew right away I was like all,
I thought it was a bad ass because I end karate.
I was beating people up in my a trading in an in taekwondo.
But when I went to Thai
boxing because we were not used to really punching the hat.
Yeah.
You know,
when they started taking my head,
my hands flew up way too high of course,
and exposing overexposing my body and that's where the body shot.
I have the exact same story.
I started out in taekwondo and realized it was like right around the time,
um,
I wanted to try to make the u s national team.
I'd won the Massachusetts State Championship like four years in a row and I won
the u s cop.
I want some,
want some good tournaments,
but I got,
or the u s open,
but I got to the nationals in 1988 by the time I was doing that though,
I'd already started boxing and I realized I was full of Shit.
Like I really like everybody that takes karate,
at least back in the day before the UFC came around,
everybody that took Judah,
everybody that took whatever you took,
you thought what you had was the shit.
That was it.
He didn't need anything else.
I got super lucky.
There was a guy named,
Joe Lake was a great guy who was a boxing coach at this gym that I was working
out at and I was teaching a taekwondo class there.
And so he started teaching me how to box,
so I had to teach him some kicks.
So I was teaching this guy some kicks and then we started doing some sparring
with a,
he bringing some boxers that I could spar with and I just got the fuck beat out
of me.
And I was like,
oh Jesus Christ,
like trying to kick box with these guys.
It was,
my hands were so terrible.
My I did,
I was so unaware of how easy it was to punch me in the face.
And I went through that extreme sort of a transition where you realize like,
wow,
I got a lot to learn.
Like I,
I developed a style that's based on no punching to the face.
So it's an unrealistic style.
But those guys that come from that unrealistic style,
because there's so many kicks,
they have a dexterity and the kicking dexterity that very few other guys ever
develop.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
it does.
There's a few guys that kick really fricking hot comb front.
I call no break arms.
She knows way that us,
you know,
he's a really good point.
Anderson Silva,
the thing that I had though,
when they beat me up to first class,
I went back home and I'd always tell my students,
I always say if I could do what you can do it in.
Oh,
because people did a,
they say,
yeah,
but it comes easy to me.
I sure maybe it can,
but I work really hard as well.
Don't alone.
Don't forget that I stood for hours in front of the mirror with my hands for
hours and I was not going to drop my hands.
And my wife at the time said,
you're crazy.
I said,
no,
no.
This will not happen again.
And the next day I went back and I just almost cleaned.
They cleaned up everybody.
They almost thought,
they thought that I was pulling a trick on them that already knew how to box.
So to tie bucks and it was just came in and I said,
no,
I spent four hours in front of the mirror yesterday,
my hands,
and they're going to drive anymore.
They guide over the liver shots.
He's still at the best of me.
He was really good.
Well that's the only way to get great is to be obsessive.
Right.
That's it.
You gotta be crazy.
I,
you know,
I tell this story and I,
you probably heard it before.
I would wake up my wife in the middle of the night because they would dream of
submission and then I would put her in that submission I would say,
hey,
it's your shoulder,
right?
Yes.
My shoulder.
I would write it down and then I would go to sleep in the next day would go,
and this happens at least six times.
This doesn't happen up and use her as
a grappling dummies.
I will wake her up and I said,
man,
I got another one.
My whole house was full of little postits.
Yeah,
I was nuts,
man.
I am already hosted.
Jerry told Mario Sperry told me once that when he was,
he was,
when I first to learn Jujitsu,
I practice a triangle.
I have my girlfriend CD in my car and I go back and it said bow and he just
would practice triangle over and over again and she's just like stabbing on and
doing my fuck you.
His girlfriend is a grappling dummy is slapping triangles on it.
I'm like,
well,
she should be honored.
That's the Mario that's,
it was buried,
but she's not with him anymore and he married her.
I don't know,
maybe it's a maybe a payback.
You got to see,
uh,
in commentating and pride,
you got to see some of the most historic sites and MMA history.
Oh,
I mean,
those days,
in my opinion.
And that's just my opinion.
I look,
I worked for the UFC.
Obviously I'm biased.
I think the greatest fighters live today.
She,
yeah.
Yeah.
I think Tj,
the level of fighters,
is that a highest,
the highest level it's ever been in the UFC,
whether it's Anderson Silva,
George Saint Pierre,
Jon Jones,
that's the highest level it's ever existed.
But as far as like the greatest events of you were there for those 90,000 seat
of just [inaudible] 91 and a half.
They came,
parachutes came in.
It was the wildest thing and Gnocchi,
right?
He lived with a parachute.
Yeah.
I had to cut off the top of the roof was opening the show.
I mean,
it was insane.
It was the craziest to Christ.
A small show would be 45,000 people.
Those considered the normal show and was this land?
How did he go?
I remember when it started,
the wind was going really hard and I go,
this is going to go wrong.
Somebody is going to be like a fly.
Squatter it up,
split it up as against whatever is there,
but I mean they came in,
they did a,
it was phenomenal.
It was the craziest thing.
The Japanese sense of pageantry.
Do you want a water or something man?
No,
no,
no.
That makes it worse with me.
I'll let like a diet coke for some reason seems to work.
Do we have anything?
I don't think we have a document that ginger ale maybe.
Yeah,
I'll try coconut water.
We have coconut water jugs of water.
I liked that.
We have coconut water,
Coco cafe.
It's coconut water with Espresso in it.
It's delicious.
Won't try that.
I'll try to get me one of them to Jamie.
Um,
please.
Uh,
but the,
the sense of pageantry that the Japanese,
I still on this TV right here,
I have best of prides and a lot of times before the,
uh,
the,
the podcasts,
I'll watch like a bunch of pride fights in a row and if sometimes I forgot,
I would saying they were,
you know,
I,
I remembered a time when Dana White was there with chocolate del,
you know,
and it was shooting down the first row waiting at a,
it started and I looked at Dana and he was like,
whoa.
I mean,
and I looked at him and I right.
It was the craziest ever that coco cafe stuff.
Um,
we don't,
these are our sponsors,
but they're cool people.
They're sending us bullshit.
It's called Coco cafe and the other stuff that's over there,
which is unbelievably delicious.
That's c two o coconut water.
Last time when I was here.
And you had that.
I buy it by the appellate now too.
You know what the good is this with the cigar?
[inaudible] is a good combination.
Yeah,
it's delicious.
Sweet coconut juice because it's from Thailand.
C Two O.
Um,
they said that they're,
those coconut trees are small.
They're only like five feet tall and not like,
oh,
regular,
crazy coconut tree,
but it's a Thai coconut that you want Amy and Brian's has the Thai coconut Nctl,
but sometimes they have the little bubbles in little show aired.
This one you can get two different ones.
The green one has a little chunks of coconut as well.
That's what I put in my morning shake.
Make a hemp force with a hemp protein or make a shake with a,
yeah.
Not even psychoactives good for everything.
No,
it's,
well,
it is good for loading everything.
That's what's crazy about it.
It will.
The hempcrete,
have you heard of this?
They got to this hemp concrete and it's,
it's actually flexible.
Yeah,
for real.
It's called hempcrete and the same,
I said they haven't had to an Olympic stadium.
Well,
they're harder than it's hot.
This is what's crazy.
They're harder than regular concrete and lighter.
And because it moves its way better for buildings because it can break,
you know,
ways nice.
Hemp is a crazy plan.
It does.
It doesn't even seem real.
And what a lot of people don't know is that it's not,
it's when you're talking about,
like you say,
hemp,
people think you're thinking of my pot and thinking about getting high.
It has nothing to do with getting high.
It has to do with it.
Yeah.
What I just mean as a,
as a product,
as a commodity,
it's an amazing plant.
Just what can do is you can get the stock like the,
the,
uh,
the base of it.
It's hard as a rock,
but yet it's a light like styrofoam.
It's crazy.
It's an alien.
It's like an alien planet.
There's no plan on the planet like him and it's illegal.
These fuckheads Jesus boss Rutan it's really illegal in Japan,
right?
I mean,
if you get caught in Japan trouble,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Was that weird spending so much time in that,
that culture?
Because Brian and I went last year.
There was a our both of our first time and we were like,
Holy Shit,
this place is nuts.
Yeah.
You brought a lot,
uh,
the,
the pills,
the THC pills.
Did you bring those love because the legal red,
you can get them on their prescription.
What's the name again of those years?
Yeah.
Fuck you up.
But I mean if you go to Japan,
you better bring that you so you want to get high,
you mean?
Yeah.
If you get offered wheat in Japan,
oh no.
It's very easy to get there.
Yeah.
No,
it's,
if you go through a bong gets all crazy things that,
yeah,
all those African dudes,
those African Jews are wandering the streets trying to offer you a massage.
Is that where we went?
Capone Gay.
That's the one.
That's the place I went to.
Like I said before,
that's what you were going,
yeah,
that's it.
They were funky.
That was it.
Was it weird though,
being over in that culture like on a regular basis?
I have a buddy with me,
so [inaudible] young and I know for four years been
bullied as was a kid until you know,
also stood up and not to bully out and start getting any wants to start
fighting.
And he's coming out here also and he's here for the first weekend and he wants
to stay for three months to train.
And he also said,
you know,
yeah,
it's hard to,
you know,
your family.
And he especially,
you know,
because he's used to his family all the time around.
And I said,
you know,
I know exactly what you're going through because I had that deal with sometimes
I went five weeks over there,
I was a hotel room and it was it,
you know,
you go in the morning,
go train,
you go back,
you eat,
you go train,
you go back and then you,
you know,
that's it.
And then you'll video games.
I was very good at fortune.
What fight or you know,
like blame these big video games there.
But that's,
there is nobody to communicate.
There's no going out district.
The only thing they have is a Roppongi.
But for the rest is not like he can walk into a bar somewhere.
It's not.
Plus you don't want to do that because you're in training.
Right.
You know,
so it's uh,
yeah,
it's hard.
It's hard to,
at that moment to be there.
This is very weird,
but the people are completely different.
You know,
it's quiet.
Everything is,
yeah,
it's a,
it's a weird feeling to me though.
I truly believe that it completely changed my fighting style.
I was a super aggressive fighter.
That's why I put this big arts on my hand in the beginning.
But in Holland I will come out very technical,
you know,
Poem Jab,
Low k,
cup up,
up,
up.
I will get hit.
You know what it was like disconnect and then it would just tear them up.
I,
that's why I got like 13 first round knockouts,
you know,
just blasted people over this.
Wouldn't we hit him out of the ring?
Almost just totally lost control.
He would try to start our technical,
but then you'd just get crazy when you go,
oh,
I got to hit that and I got so angry and I,
and then when I went to Japan I realized,
well these guys are known to to take a hit,
you know?
And I figured if I,
when I found out that there was the funniest part,
no way classes.
So my guy was two 45 I go and that's not a problem here.
No.
I said,
okay,
good,
good.
So I'm bluffing now,
right?
I says,
well how many runs?
We got?
Five.
They said,
no one run.
I said,
well great,
how many minutes?
30 I said,
Oh yeah,
great,
great.
But in my mind I went,
Fuck.
And
so that's why I put the arms on my head.
I go,
yeah,
if I,
if I unload myself the first two minutes I got 28 minutes to go,
you know,
I don't want to take that risk.
And you like that better?
Do you prefer?
And like,
like when you see like the pride 10 minute round,
the opening round,
there's a lot of debate about that as well.
Whether or not the,
uh,
the 10 minute opening round is better or the three five,
you know.
Well,
I,
I get tell you what they did 10 minute opening round,
uh,
makes for a better strategical fighter that that's for sure.
Because you got,
people have no cool how techy can get in one minutes or in it too much.
I have these one minute drills that are doing the bag that pros come in and they
go home and he mine,
you know,
I mean,
but I go berzerk you know,
give you combination.
Everything is 100%.
You know,
saying this before I forget,
someone's been asking on the underground can,
do you still,
do you still sell those Bas Rutten workout tapes?
Yeah.
Still every month I used to get to finally using it.
[inaudible] dot com [inaudible] dot com you sell it.
Okay.
Yup.
Because a,
there was a bunch of people that were a on mixed martial arts.com MMA out.
You will have that workout is going to be your best friend.
When I trained myself,
it's always part of my work for real.
Once you did it ever with the numbers,
it's great.
It's great because you can do it anywhere.
You can do it in the,
in the hotel.
I was in the hotel room,
I put the band to the side with the sprawls and everything.
It was quite fun.
It's a fun workout.
Yeah,
I love that.
But the 10 minutes opening route,
if you overstretch yourself,
shoot yourself in the beginning of the round,
you know,
you,
you're going to have eight minutes left and eight minutes is a very long time,
you know,
to,
to come back from that.
So I truly believe you know,
you,
you play always that danger as an uh,
as a fighter.
That's why I'll always send to all my guys,
the 38 year old guy who I said we're starting fighting.
I said stamina is going to be your number one goal.
The technique.
We put that.
Number two,
I want stamina at one.
Right.
You know,
because if you run out of gas,
you can have a hundred black belts is not going to save you.
You're going to get knocked out.
And he really did that.
He can go and especially with amateurs,
you get short rounds peak and blast them all day long.
He's never,
and that's how we,
you know,
he had a heart first round and then the guy started getting more tired and then
the third round here he just destroyed the guy knocked him out.
And that's what finding you,
you play a little bit of a risk factor.
That's why I always trained so hard.
I didn't want to have that risk factor in there.
I never run out of gas in my life.
Yeah.
You were never a guy that had a short gas tank even in the cold Soka fight where
you couldn't train grappling.
Yup.
And he took you down and he was,
you know,
he's basically trying to out grapple you in that fight.
He didn't want to stand with you.
You still manage to have the conditioning to take them out on the feet.
Yeah.
Look a sacrifice.
It was also,
I will show my backdoor escapes with,
uh,
and I always said,
I said,
watch that fight.
He takes me down.
She,
how long,
how long has gotten me,
I think what,
20 seconds I'm out.
You know,
it's just backdoor escapes.
But I would go over and over and over again.
You know,
I will,
when I do something to enjoy yoga,
I do,
I do.
It is black and white with me.
I'll go all the way and,
and,
and more.
Will you styles always very interesting to me.
It's,
it's always,
it's fascinating how many different people have a different approach.
Like Nick Diaz is approach where he throws like,
he'll hit you with like 50% punches.
He'll just come at you like,
have you seen the video of him shadowboxing by the way?
Or a hitting the speed bag.
Brion pull this up.
Nick Diaz hits the fucking speed bag for 23 minutes in a row.
Wow.
It's insane.
And I was one to three minutes in a row.
I did this five minute rounds,
three minutes,
and then,
oh,
by the way,
he had ridden his bike 15 fucking miles.
I'm not bullshitting.
He rode his bike 15 miles to the gym,
sparred five,
five minute rounds,
hit the pads and then does this 23 fucking do anything with me as though I'll do
one,
one I don't do about dig it,
dig it.
I don't do that and I go date.
They get,
they get,
they get to get,
I go like really fast like that,
you know?
But that is crazy.
That is really,
yes.
No liked it.
Essence.
It's amazing.
I mean he's,
he's got incredible conditioning and he's a,
you know,
he's a couple of days away from the fight.
That's this weekend,
this Saturday night,
George Saint Pierre and him are going down.
It's going to be crazy.
Oh,
in Montreal.
This is 23 minutes of this.
He does this boss and at the end of it all,
he's not even that tired.
I mean,
it's fucking crazy.
This guy's not doing this at a slow pace.
Look at this.
Nick Diaz has,
in my opinion,
he's got the best cardio in in all of them.
But you see he's doing what I said.
He don't just do it more than other people.
Look at this man just saying,
if he does this for 23 minutes yet,
guess why he doesn't get burned out in a shoulders cause I always doing it
because the reason he does it so often,
and by the way,
when he's not doing it,
he's fucking doing triathlons.
The guys swam from Alcatraz twice,
you know?
Crazy.
You have to be in the water up there.
Phil would sharks.
Yeah.
Great White Meeting Habitat.
That was a big a myth also right at that time that they put planet people's
heads so they wouldn't start swimming back.
Oh No.
It's just stream is that is the worst.
The stream that that takes people out there.
Most dangerous.
Yeah.
The time.
There's,
there's a lot of shit is dangerous.
First of all.
Water.
It's really fucking cold up there.
Yeah.
But you know what?
That's what I say again.
What he got this you can do,
do you just have to do it?
You just have to do it,
you know,
and that's what the people were.
They run it against go run a fricking hill man.
I mean that's what I used.
One of the things that you said or you said,
uh,
you,
you said I would do one round,
I would start out one minute.
Yup.
And I would go full clip and then next time I don't want a minute and a half and
then eventually you build up.
That's it.
But you got to,
that was your style of doing it though.
And,
and you know what I do,
I have those one minute drills on a bag.
I have all that.
We'll be focusing.
It's a type,
it's what you just talked about.
But I will take it even easier.
What I will do is one minute on the bag,
one minute rest and I will do 15 rounds as 30 minutes.
Then I would go to next week,
one minute of five seconds on the back,
55 seconds rest next week for one minute,
10 seconds,
56 every time,
five seconds more and five seconds away from your rest time at the end you're at
one and a half minute going crazy on the back of every punch is dis through hit
through someone's head,
like there's not one half point and then what have you done in like 30 seconds
rest and then 30 seconds for us,
one and a half minutes fall.
You see guys in,
in,
um,
in fight it and fight who suddenly unload themselves for 20,
30 seconds and the guest out.
Right?
Right.
How many times do you see that?
How many times?
Well,
there's the drill for you.
This,
you know,
you're going to be bizarre,
strong and every time it's just five seconds more,
you know,
every week.
So if she was fine slowly and that you do together with the other drills that I
said going to the fight for the six minutes,
right.
From
what I was getting at with the Nick Diaz thing was that it's,
it's so interesting to see the different styles.
Like the way nick approaches it where he just says a lot of volume.
Volume.
Yeah.
He doesn't blast you full blast with every shot.
Whereas you had a different style.
You would even when you would,
you would kick their arms,
you would try
to crush them.
You try to break down.
I'm afraid of it.
Like I say,
if somebody puts his defense off up kick as hard as she can on a defense put in
his head that I bet a blog this,
because if I don't look at,
you know,
now you're inside his head,
do you?
She already great.
But Nick Diaz hips has a different muscles than I have.
I have the fast twitch fibers.
A lot of guys that they have that they burn a lot but he doesn't have,
he had to slow twitch fibers and I'm not,
that doesn't mean it's slow,
but I mean it has a different,
he is the the insurance guy.
So a lot of them have that,
you know,
but all the explosive guys,
they really have to watch out how they fight,
burst,
look,
relax,
burst,
relax.
You know you have to fight like a train like that because otherwise you run
against,
that's why you see all those super explosive guys they run out against and
that's the reason because they don't train like that.
One of the things that are Chael Sonnen serve,
he said that if you try to knock a guy out,
if you feel like you have an opportunity,
you try to knock the guy out.
If you don't knock them out,
you're probably not going to win a decision.
Like,
do you have to realize you're,
you're gambling at all.
Yeah.
But Guy Survives it.
You might be,
might be out of gas.
Yeah.
But she all has the same thing.
It was also no knockout power.
You know.
He just told us volume,
volume,
volume.
You're like,
uh,
Nick Diaz,
he's got,
he's got knockout power.
If he wants,
he can drop on,
you know,
but you see it,
you can be chill.
He has got an incredible stamina is c and that's those,
those,
those muscles.
It's wrapping on the dude.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's a,
it's just such a fascinating thing to see guys start to put it all together.
And also the sea,
the whole style changing where these guys like these Roy McDonald guys that can
do everything are starting to sort of move ahead.
And it was explosive,
explosive also and does a lot of explosive drills.
He received his workouts.
He's doing a lot of like jumping over a,
those horses,
you know,
those uh,
saw horses,
those barriers,
what do they call?
Hurdles.
Hurdle.
A lot of hurdle jumping.
A lot of like power lifting.
A lot of like all the strength and conditioning shit that you see with like pro
football players,
pro hockey players.
That's what you're seeing now.
He's,
you see him like real athletes.
Yep.
And also guys that have multifaceted attacks for the longest time,
like I've always said like,
gosh,
she's throwing my leg kicks and people would get pissed at me.
They're like,
why do you keep saying that?
You know he's doing well on his own.
I'm like,
because it's not,
you can do better.
Yeah.
I mean,
and whom I did say it well,
yeah,
who am I?
But I'm also a guy seen a thousand fights and I,
I know what people,
some people can do.
I know there are guys,
when you see a guy like Anderson Silva who basically we can do everything.
And when you see that guy,
you know that those guys are possible.
So when you see a guy who doesn't,
or when you see a guy like George St Pierre who makes it so unpredictable,
what he's going to do,
whether he's going to punch you or try to take you down.
And that's part of why he so effective.
It's because he's,
you know,
he's moving,
he moves really well.
It covers distance really well.
And you don't know if he's shooting a double over,
he's throwing a punch at you.
You don't know.
He makes you mix.
It makes you worry about it.
He's like the La Jolla I used to do,
you know how you would go to a fight and every time he will bring a new thing to
a fight and that will be his focus on and,
and,
and GSB has the same thing.
Lifers is when he fought shake,
it was to Jab,
Jab,
and it was that spinning back.
He comes with two or three things and he will throw that the most.
And in between he adlibs and he,
he does all the rest that he knows the spinning backwards from him working with
me.
Oh yeah.
The whole video of me teaching them how to do it.
Oh Nice.
I,
we were at a,
at legends and Hollywood and it was the most ridiculous conversation.
I was talking to John Donner and he was looking for someone to teach George
Saint Pierre how to throw a spinning back kick.
He was asking me,
do you know any good talk when no guys,
here we go.
I'm going to go.
This is gonna sound crazy.
You're not going to believe me.
I go,
but I got to fucking nasty tourney sock take.
It was like my number one technique I could show him.
And so I worked with George on it.
We went over like a,
a lot of it.
He like,
he already had a decent one.
Yeah,
he just was,
he had a couple of rotates over,
over rotating and a lot of it was the,
the low knee kicking up as opposed to the higher goal kicking straight.
Yeah.
Like that Tuck one knows style.
You started in that way from the knee backwards.
Yeah.
The back kick is higher with us.
I'll lift it up higher now as far as lifting enough hires where you get the real
power because they don't involve the hip and a full rotation.
They're the only the only example Peter Smith,
you know,
remember speeding ticket.
I as a first time I saw me,
he was doing a cute machine tournament and um,
I think he wanted us six fights it and one day oh by spinning back kick.
And that was,
that was that cake.
Hey,
I need to judge in front of neat.
He had a nasty one,
but it was so ridiculous.
Heart.
It was like when the guy would crumple and it was the craziest thing ever.
What a guy too,
man.
He's uh,
he's up there now with the Roman for sure because those guys,
they knew each other as well.
Peter Smith.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
A lot of great personnel.
So man.
Yeah,
he fought a funny guy,
man.
I mean he fought,
he fought a lot of tod guys too,
right?
Yeah.
It's hilarious.
Yeah,
guys that will mix up.
Like I always loved it.
And the guy was a mix up,
uh,
karate techniques and taekwondo techniques with the Moitai like,
like Andy Hook.
I mean,
you throw that,
we'll kick to the thigh,
you know,
that's how we won the whole thing with Bernardo.
Bernardo got his legs messed up already with Peter Earths and everybody,
you know,
and then he smart.
It was a smart guy.
Andy Hook who did that.
Nobody ever did that and he did.
Then he knocked him out like that to their legs.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
It's an amazing technique that we'll kick to the leg.
There's so much power to it.
You know it,
man.
It's like those couple era guys today.
I had a question on Facebook or if a pure couple where a guy against the pure
Thai boxer who was going to win and then I go,
but okay,
well I'll,
I'll take the pure Thai boxer.
I say holidays.
I don't mean like a then Tyler,
but I say the Thai book show of course,
because they will probably close to this and it's really fast.
It had been in hand range and couple of era doesn't have that,
you know,
and they have only kicks in and he's spinning.
But once a cake hits,
I mean they will.
I mean they have so much power when they propel that way,
the way they throw that cake but landing it,
that's the thing,
you know,
and there's a lot
of movement.
A lot of movement is easy detectable.
It's like when Leo Machida in that front kick on Randy,
that jumping front kick to the
more crazy,
the reason he could do it is because he's got good wrestling.
He's got a black belt in Jujitsu is your good hands.
He's got to all the other things as well.
And so then you can add those karate techniques and then they become incredibly
deadly.
Yeah.
Talking about a Machita asked may be good to mention because one time I said,
yeah,
he doesn't have a lot of weapons.
I didn't mean it like that.
What?
I mean,
they said he doesn't use a lot of weapons.
He's got the faith,
very southpaw stance in one light karate stance,
which shuts them down for the right.
Like he has a sidekick,
but at the roundhouse kick you don't need to be worried about because he can't
use his power in there.
And I'm not saying people go like,
oh sure,
we can knock you out.
I'm not saying that we saw Kimbo getting knocked out with the weirdest little
tiny points.
Everybody could get knocked out when you hit them at the wrong time.
The wrong spot for him.
And you had to write down my spot.
But he says his,
his attacks,
emotional time,
it's the left straight or it's a left kick left straight.
Right.
Or a left kick left straight.
Right Hook.
And when he moves backwards,
I said he always moves to that site and if you bull rush him because of his
stance,
he has to start walking backwards because otherwise he can't move backwards fast
enough.
And that's what I meant to,
you know.
But he always like that with a front kick.
He brings something,
you know,
he has those same attacks,
but he knows him very well.
He's got really precision accuracy.
And then on top of that,
his,
his counters are bizarre,
but he's a tech is pretty much those attacks.
Machida gets a lot of heat and you got a lot of heat in the Dan Henderson fight.
You know,
I thought when I was interviewing him after the fight,
the whole audience was booing him.
And I thought that was kind of fucked up because I thought first of all,
Dan Henderson is incredibly dangerous,
very,
very dangerous guys.
Super Powerful puncher,
ruthless,
very aggressive and lots of experience knocking people out,
data centers and knocked out,
fade or knocked out.
Vandelay not,
I mean,
who knows how to put knuckles to chin,
you know,
he's,
he's a,
he's a spooky God.
And there's only one way to fight him and not get knocked out.
Don't get hit by him.
Yes.
And so Machida's number one will don't get hit by that fucking nuclear weapon.
This guys packing.
And I thought that was an exciting fight.
It wasn't exciting for,
but I,
I can understand that people,
because he's a counterfeiter,
he waits for Henderson Henderson though.
I thought right from the get go he throws one punch and he stays there and I go,
he's going to get knocked out now because,
but she is very good at countering.
I thought if I would fight,
if I was Henderson with this wrestling,
I would just run on him,
run,
put them up against,
he knows he's got to go that way because he doesn't find 95%.
You Watch the day before,
take him down and go for ground and pound.
But whatever you do,
don't throw single punches or two punch combinations because he's so good at the
counter.
Yeah.
I think when I see a lot of older wrestlers,
like a Dan,
I mean I,
I know Dan,
uh,
recently had a knee injury and his knee was really wrapped up for that fight.
I always assume that they're going in,
they're banged up.
Yup.
Always assume.
Extend Sandra Hubba.
Yeah.
And I think with Dan especially because he's got so much knockout power,
it probably avoid the grappling.
I mean in bed he's got back issues.
Yeah.
I mean I'm sure he does these guys.
I mean it's fucking brutal way to make a living.
And the 42 now,
I think he's 14
he's demands meant though.
I really liked that.
Then it's the,
you know,
the weight when he fought a fade or you know,
that's fatal,
came out banging and then you see him making up his mind like,
oh,
is it going to be like that?
Yeah.
Okay,
I can do that too.
And then he freaking came,
you know,
and that's what I love about that man.
He said,
I saw him,
it prides like after the first rock crawling on his knees back to the corner and
then he would come out and say,
come on,
like nothing happened and just fight again.
He's a tough motherfucker.
He took that first Vandelay fight.
He was not in good shape.
You could tell he just wasn't in conditioning enough for that fight.
And that was a scary fight for him at one point in time when the family was
mounting them and pounding on him,
beating everybody have ventilators at time.
Yeah.
Angela was a spooky,
spooky dude back then.
And you know,
and also this is in pride where there's no drug testing.
Yup.
So you mean you could be on Epo,
testosterone,
you name it.
I mean,
it was just,
everybody knows that it's the dirty little thing that nobody wants to talk
about.
Those mother fuckers are juicy
gills.
It's,
you know,
you'll,
I always say,
just look at the bodies and then look at their bodies,
how they changed it the most of the time.
There you have the answer,
you know.
And on top of that they didn't get tired.
Yeah.
I didn't get tired.
It was the craziest thing ever.
Yeah.
Vandelay in his prime back then,
man.
He was so fucking scary.
Oh cool.
Was it to see back in Japan that fight?
Who's amazing?
Wow.
And I'm beat Brian Stann classic Vandelay.
You know what I liked about that fight too?
He didn't cut down to one 85 yup.
I think that that's no good for him.
Pick.
It hurts him.
I tell everybody,
you know,
this is the thing with fighters,
a budge of fighters.
When they lose in the certain way class,
they blame it on the outer person cutting more weight than them.
That's why they were starting.
I said,
dude,
make up a technique,
you know,
get more stamina and more technique and work harder.
You know?
That's what I would do.
I always find heavyweight also.
I could easily fight under two and a punch.
I was under 200 pounds,
but I didn't want to do it because I saw all these guys,
all my friends getting sick.
I mean they were all shrunk.
God before the five that him stressed out.
You know,
I say keep the body happy man.
You knew your,
you're beating it up everyday already two times a day.
The only thing I could do for it,
there's give her what it wants and I'll give him all the fluids,
nutrients,
give it to them and,
and,
and don't pull that out is the worst thing you can do.
People don't understand what we're talking about if you're not into MMA,
but there's a real issue in mixed martial arts with weight cutting.
And what that means is we'll guys will way say if you had to get down to 170
pounds,
there's guys that way,
like Anthony Rumble Johnson well over 200 pounds,
well over 200 pounds.
He's enormous.
He's fighting heavyweight now Anthony Rumble Johnson and I think of March 23rd
he's fighting our Lawsky and heavyweight.
He used to cut down to one 70 and what that means is you essentially starve
yourself and then dehydrate yourself and dehydrate yourself the day before the
fight,
to the point where guys would black out,
guys would lose their,
they could move their legs,
like literally their legs would stop working or they would have to fight in a
cage fight.
The next day
we had to pull her to ski to the Sada.
You know,
you'll pass out.
He lost a one 27 pounds in a day and the end today,
the guide,
the,
he's a young kid letting commissioner said that it was the biggest difference
you've Edis ever saw.
That's almost two weight classes up that he was 27 or 28 even pounds heavier the
next day.
Didn't hoard,
hoard.
Dusky was like 18 at the time.
Yeah,
I was very young.
I think,
yeah,
1819 bucks when he started fighting it,
the IFL.
So,
and I remember the first time because he fought the guy from Hanzo and I go,
oh my God,
because it's a baby,
you know,
you look at me
and a,
and Shaun goes,
don't you worry about it,
you watch.
And that he started man went to town and he became a fan favorite right away.
Yeah.
He uh,
he looked like he had a little bit of body fat on them though.
I mean,
yeah,
at the time.
Yeah.
He could have like lost the weight correctly.
Yeah,
that's true.
They're longer weight cutting,
man.
It's just so,
but then again,
some guys not to do it well like look at Benson Henderson.
Yeah.
He does a great,
he doesn't look sucked in.
He is obviously very,
very lean.
Yeah.
He's disciplined about it.
And because of that,
when he fights,
he's got all the stamina in the world.
He can do five,
five minute rounds,
no problem.
And you know,
he's huge.
He's huge for one.
Some guys don't,
they,
they used it,
they drink two gallons of water a day.
You know,
that's a lot of pilots right there.
And if you only have to cut that out,
then it's easy.
But I think once you start cutting before and you start eating away muscle,
you know that you're doing it wrong.
And once the reserves are going to be asked for in the body and they're gonna
say,
okay,
I,
I truly believe like the brain fluid she got,
God knows why you're taking them away.
They're also,
you know,
and that is the reason to the brain is balancing upside down.
And that's why people get to,
you know,
uh,
brain damage and people don't know this.
But in boxing,
I believe all of the deaths ever recorded.
We're below the heavyweight division because the heavyweights,
I mean,
there might be some,
you know,
some rare occurrences boxing's a tough game.
Some people might have died as a heavy heavyweight,
but most of the incidents is we're in the lighter weight classes when guys cut a
lot of weight.
And that was when they used to have the way in the day of the fight.
And that was also when they weren't using ivs.
But a lot of folks don't know is when you see these guys,
they dehydrate themselves.
One of the things that's sick about it is they go and they get fucking ivy bags
stuck in there.
I get a needle in their arm and they replenish their fluids that right?
Yeah.
I would walk in a room and the whole room,
everybody would sit there and there's hanging everywhere,
you know,
and they get retained.
How about fucking blood?
I know a guy who uh,
went into a room or one of the fighters is way back in the day and the guy had
fucking pints of blood out that they were putting back in.
But you see if that's blood coming out of the fridge,
that's like EPO white blood cells.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
And he was also doing it to,
to make weight.
They were taking blood out of them to make weight and adding extra blood in
idiot Smith like that EPO shits what they're doing right now.
Also,
you know this like your blood gets really thick,
your heart rate gets really low.
You have to,
some of these guys have to wake up in the middle of the night,
jumped 10 minutes on a bike or,
or you know,
in,
in the home to have it end up in the bedroom because otherwise the heart stopped
beating and I go,
do you really want to get a title like that?
Plus when you get your title and you cheated,
what if you use steroids or anything and you get a title?
How can you,
I was still these people.
If I brushed my teeth,
I can look at myself in the mirror.
I did everything without cheating.
Nothing ever in my body other than just good food in your teeth.
When you brush your teeth and you look at yourself in the mirror,
you're going to go like,
and he was a cheater.
I was like,
how competitive are you a toothbrush taking steroids to brush your teeth?
Oh Hey,
you know what?
You're going to laugh.
You got to my wife's lesser ass off every time she,
because my little daughter is the same as me,
like,
like movement wise,
she bounces all day long.
Ding,
Ding.
You know and dancing 11 o'clock at night and when you hear a brushing her teeth
because she says the same as me,
it's a lot of power to have the same things and aware of her.
It's Hilarious,
you know.
And the other one says it's so cool when you see one room for my daughter it's,
it's a garbage field and the other one is like everything is perfect.
Like the codepen is perfectly on the faith.
That's funny how their personality is the best.
I have one my two year old that I think might be a lesbian,
I don't have any problem with that,
but my wife does.
When I say she's a dyke,
she goes and she goes and picks up like she goes and goes,
grabs like Batman and Spiderman.
She always wants to play with the hawk.
She wants to play with boys toys.
She likes it.
Maybe she likes boys very much.
So it be also,
she sees me work out.
So she comes over,
she tries punching and kicking the bag.
She's very aggressive.
Oh it's the best.
She's,
but the other ones like girly and Princessy said he's built different too.
She has like thick ankles and shit.
Probably a dike.
You got to see what I have.
No,
I love lesbians,
man.
You know my wife's like,
don't say that.
And I'm like,
how can you can?
Yeah.
Not only that,
but my wife has gay friends.
She loves gay people.
You know?
I think you're the people with the left brain capacity.
They have all problems with it.
I truly believe you know the Trans Gender who's fighting?
And they asked me your last week,
I said,
who?
Who even cares?
I care.
They need to fight transgenders.
If a transgender is going to find the need to find out what you think.
So yeah.
Fuck yeah.
Why you think he's going to get her horny?
Oh,
no,
no.
Physical.
Have an advantage
for the mechanical advantage of the male body.
Oh,
let's show he fights.
Gail kills.
Yeah.
No,
I didn't.
I didn't know that.
No,
no,
no.
I thought he fought guys.
Oh,
no,
no.
Dad.
No,
no.
Yeah,
of course.
He's got testosterone.
Me Mobby International Olympic Committee.
If you've been a transgender,
if you've cut off within two years,
I think two year after two years,
they allow you to compete against women until they see.
I didn't know that.
Yeah,
I think it's ridiculous.
No,
I thought just fighting with guys.
Is it?
Come on.
No,
I don't care.
But the guys,
they would get killed without the testosterone.
They'd get killed.
You get your balls cut off and then fight against guys,
you're going to get killed.
There's a famous Muay Thai fighter who was a,
a lady boy who,
oh,
Yay.
Fought really well.
Kohler lady boils.
Yeah.
And then she got the operation and then she started getting knocked out because
once she got the operation,
became a woman.
She didn't have testosterone anymore.
She started really getting fucked up.
But it's still,
I mean,
you might not be able to beat men after you get your Dick cut off,
but you just took a beat.
Women.
Yep.
The tendons,
the ligaments,
the bone density.
Especially because she's,
she's not just like walking around.
She's training for MMA.
Yeah.
So like she has a male body.
That's his training for MMA.
And I looked at her and she's so bulky,
man.
I'm like,
man,
I can't believe that this chick is not taking something which has no balls
anymore.
How she keeping this much muscle mass?
I mean,
she looks like a muscular man.
It's gross.
That's that.
That's that cold though.
Fight out of guys then that I'm okay with it.
How'd you feel about that whole sideboard thing when Cyborg tested positive for
steroids?
Well,
you don't know who that is focused.
So cyborg is a,
one of the scariest women fighters and she's a real woman,
but she's very masculine and very muscular.
And she's,
uh,
she tested positive.
Well,
she,
she says she didn't do it.
I get it.
But people will say that,
but I,
I,
nobody was a shock.
Right.
That by the way,
she looks,
she looks indeed that she's doing,
I mean the way after the fight when she was throwing up her husband at the time
to divorce,
now,
you know,
it was like,
Whoa,
she is a normal,
strong.
She was like,
she was so,
it was a,
you know,
it was not a big surprise,
but I always say,
you know,
if you really,
if they say no and they say no,
I gotta you know,
you,
you have to believe them.
I think it's the,
the,
it will be very sad.
But that's me.
I could not lie like that.
It could not live in a line like that.
If I have to lie about that and my whole life is aligned now suddenly.
So I say,
okay,
here's the reality.
The reality is she came from a Brazilian camp known for aggressive fighters that
may or may not have taken substances as well.
So there's,
there's that issue,
right?
That's that that's legit in escapable and then too,
she tested positive.
Yeah.
And once he tests positive,
I mean it's essentially why would we believe you any other,
you look like you're on steroids and you test positive for steroids.
Yup.
That is just as much of an issue to me as a transgender woman or a man who used
to be,
well you mean when you said it,
but to try and shit you heard
now with the ovary,
I,
I read that last week with the injury,
I heard something on the day of inside of a May they said,
oh,
it was an injury.
I truly believed the reason because his testosterone was Alistair Overeem's
testosterone level was [inaudible] 79 so I thought that was the reason he was
not going to fight in,
in the VA because Keith guys were at set prior usage,
you know,
and that's the reason.
That's why he cannot find it.
So I'm going to explain everything.
We were talking about his testosterone use exemption,
uh,
Tue for testosterone replacement therapy.
So very controversial issue now with MMA fighters where there are taking
testosterone because the body doesn't produce it as much anymore.
And there's two reasons for that.
There's three actually.
One is just the natural aging process or natural aging process and once you get
over 30,
you body starts producing less and less testosterone.
I would say 25 maybe.
Well No,
it slowly read it to you don't need it.
No,
you certainly don't need it.
But the good true issue though is when guys have taken steroids in the past,
they take them for prolonged periods of time and then it kills their balls and
so then they test really low.
That's most likely what's going on with Allister.
And then Keith guys have said if they find out that you prior usage,
because Ellis to was caught before,
this is for listeners at home,
you know,
by using testosterone.
Then they said,
okay,
you cannot get it.
As soon as the fight was in Vegas.
I thought,
oh,
that is the reason.
But then under day of the show they said,
oh no,
he just released it was his hamstring.
And so,
so when I sat there story,
I said,
well,
I thought it was that testosterone daily was with people,
right.
People right away because I said something about Ellis to like over a year and a
half ago or something to go like,
oh,
it's only because he have golden glory and you know,
all the,
all that stuff.
I go,
dude,
I grew over,
you grow over it.
I don't have a problem with it.
I'm just saying what I read this week,
you know,
and I thought was the reason he couldn't compete in Nevada because Keith geysers
there,
um,
for folks who don't know what the fuck we're talking about,
testosterone is,
um,
the,
it's all,
it's,
it's a huge controversial issue.
Now Vitor Belfort is another example of it because Keith Kaiser has said that
because of the fact that he tested positive for steroids in 2006,
I believe it was.
I think it was when the pride that was,
yeah,
at that time,
Vegas,
right.
Fight against Dan Henderson.
When you test positive for steroids,
they won't,
if you have a,
you know,
any history of doing that,
they assumed that the reason why your test is low is cause you ruined your body.
And if that's the case,
you're on your own because you cheated.
If you have a,
a real medical condition for why your testosterone is low,
then they'll grant exemptions and they've granted them for Forrest Griffin and a
bunch of other guys.
Dan Henderson,
famous Andy's shift 42 years old or something,
you know,
now we started with talking to h here,
but,
but a guy who's 30 or under 35 and he should not have low testosterone.
He shoot,
not unless he's going to a medical condition.
Yeah.
You know,
I had guys that do will look at me in the shed.
No.
And I really need it.
And I go,
dude,
I remember you when you were two 25 you'll bagful of Zichy were freaking huge.
Now you're fighting a one 55 and now you want an exemption because,
oh no,
I have something with my colon.
And whatever they say,
I say,
you know what the reason is don't be,
don't be here lying to me now.
You know,
and nobody ever wants to admit my boss work cause I took Roy too much.
Yeah.
But so like B [inaudible] who's active in the UFC and he's doing really well,
just knocked out Michael Bisping and how he's going to fight again.
He's gonna fight in Brazil.
He's got to,
he's,
he can never fight in Vegas now.
That's what I said also in our show.
I,
I gave the example of Alistair and I and I said,
because he said to the same thing with Frito Belfort and of course they attacked
me with or your or it goes to Ellis too because you left called the glory.
No,
no,
everybody is the same.
You know when I said he had a glass jaw,
I didn't say that.
Look,
if he will closest friend,
I would mention it.
You know,
we did not many people need to know,
but then,
you know,
otherwise I say it,
I said about gave last because I love game of Alaska.
I think he's a great fighter,
but I,
you know,
he's,
he's not a super strong chin,
you know,
but he's an unbelievable fighter.
You can see what you can do.
You know what I mean?
He took it to her junior.
The sound so amazing.
Is this fight going to happen now because I don't know any more.
Junior or first was hunters that,
oh yes.
Oh my God.
That's going to be a junior man.
Yeah,
I love,
I love when guys like you hear about that fine and go,
oh,
you don't know man.
I know he has Marcos Hunt.
You can't knock him out to do as our mother fucker.
Well,
you can knock them out.
I mean the Melvin Malcolm and you see that fight.
Okay.
Watch defining slow motion.
I bet you because we are still cups in Holland,
right?
He knocks him down.
Yes,
she,
he lose.
He falls forward.
But hunt falls on his cup.
Watch you see book hitting the Cup at any flights down I go,
I guarantee you the extra.
Yeah,
there's Steel Cup put sealed the deal.
Know Steel Decay,
but I remember Mirko Cro cop kicking him with his freaking shit in the face and
he just took a knee.
No,
the first time he did a flinch at all and the second time he took a knee and he
got up like freaking terminator and it kept going.
Super Samoan.
Scary Guy,
man.
He can,
he can bang,
Bang.
You see that right on the spot there,
right on this bug where you hit that hook,
that overhand Hizo way,
way more experienced striker than anybody else in the UFC.
He said the only thing that guys in on his level as far as experiences Allister,
cause he's the only other guy that won the Grand Prix.
Yup.
And Allison won the Grand Prix clean.
Whereas,
um,
hunt one it because that crazy Friday I would race SFO and then ray Sefo
couldn't continue.
So he went and he took race F I was placing one it right.
You know,
but yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No he did.
But I think got to say a Saki normally because I ended up,
when they spar,
you know,
I know who is half yeah.
But,
uh,
over Anna and [inaudible] to the finals with a broken hand and a broken arm,
you know,
so we,
uh,
so that would be a great five between the two of those when both are healthy.
I love the fact that a k k one it's not really k one as much as it is glory now.
And uh,
you know,
there was a,
there's,
there's just been more high level kickboxing on television these days.
It's really coming back.
It's a great show.
It really is a great show,
you know,
and uh,
such high level strikes.
I was here at,
uh,
at the airport,
they're the casino.
They have there somewhere,
you know,
on a century.
I was there about four weeks ago.
There was a glory show and I was amazed with the teller they had here.
Like I was truly amazed to kickbox and tells coming from America and uh,
that was not in the past like this,
you know,
and these guys look really good.
Well,
I think MMA is fed it to the point where everybody realized how important
[inaudible] skills are to win an MMA.
And then more people started gravitating towards Moy Moitai.
Yup.
And then,
you know,
I think we're,
we're seeing when you see the highest level,
like you see like a Giorgio Petrosian or something like that,
like a real high level technical guy.
Like you realize like wow,
the level of striking,
which is probably the most entertaining,
entertaining and exciting part of MMA.
Yeah.
The level of striking is way higher in like high level kickboxing that it is an
MMA right.
Way Higher.
No,
for sure.
Like Anderson I think could,
could Pete and high level kickboxing,
you know,
still shop at the high cakes like his knees and,
and he's crazy like Trump kitchen timing and his hands are specifically really
good.
I don't know if he's got a really good roundhouse kick to the head.
I never really see a meg that you shouldn't have common.
Like in the past it,
you should in the SEC first round,
they're fine to you if she,
yeah,
that's true.
Okay,
good,
good.
Roundhouse.
Kicked him in the face,
stunned them.
Then the bell rang and then he finished him off in the next round.
Yeah.
It gets to chill.
He threw it from a weird angle I thought.
And I go like,
Whoa Dad.
But uh,
I think it was just,
he was,
he was too excited to fight,
chill.
And he really wants at the time on it though.
And that's when you start making those little like Ms. Gay mistakes that fight
with Stephan Bonner fight was the most brutal version of Anderson Silva.
That was incredible.
That was,
I was literally,
if I,
there was a moment in my life and my mouth was open.
That was the moment when he just moved back,
move,
move.
And it goes boof,
pressed against the cage.
I go home and he stopped him with that needle.
And Stephan Bonner,
of course,
I've been in Brazil,
Forrest,
Forrest Griffin,
Forrest Griffin was,
that was in my mind.
That was just unbelievable.
It was just the most amazing thing ever.
He manhandled them.
So moving,
letting miss cause that mission and go Boehnke ride on that button.
You know?
So beautiful.
He's so accurate.
Do you think he's the best ever?
You know?
Yeah.
He's up there with Federer.
I still put up Darryl so I cannot all these great fights.
We saw it.
Pride.
It's gotta be up there man.
Because,
but yeah,
he right now,
I mean,
who gets stopped,
fade or in his prime,
like the Nogueira days wouldn't beat Noguera.
He was unbelievable when he beat Cro cop,
you know,
he was so good back then.
She's beating
and the way he did it,
so called
I will love to see as prime or prime fade or versus a prime Cain Velasquez.
Yeah.
If we could go back in time with,
with Kane,
take the cane of today back or fight fade or Ooh,
yeah,
yeah.
That would have been an amazing fight.
Yeah.
Good stuff.
We were so lucky now to see this evolution of Shit and Cain is another one of
those guys that just,
uh,
you know,
he's got a full skillset,
throws,
leg kicks,
head kicks,
punches,
you know,
and the stamina.
I love that.
Although in the junior dos Santos Friday start running out again,
it's also,
you know,
not to lift this pace,
but the strength got away,
you know,
to ground and pound was not,
not effective anymore,
not to knock them out.
And we threw 100 million punches.
Nobody's is saying what heavyweight.
And everybody goes,
well,
one guy told me one time,
uh,
I say,
yeah,
but I'm heavyweight to say,
well look,
okay for [inaudible].
And he goes,
Yo buddy trains really hard.
And I go,
really did,
that's,
that's the answer.
You
give it to yourself.
Well,
three really hard.
Um,
he was,
he's a relatively small heavyweight.
He's a little heavier than you at about two 40,
but realistically cane,
when you look at him has,
he carries more body fat as well.
Yeah.
You know,
it's interesting how the,
it seems like that's about as big as you need to get.
Like those big 265 pound guys that cut weight and get you,
you,
oh,
you almost sacrifice something.
You do always,
always.
And I think the cane has that burning inside from his family and know what they
showed on TV when they did those specials on them.
And then he wants to provide for his family.
He's got the,
the whole,
you know,
his old fun and work in heart and he's got that mentality and I think a guy like
that,
you know,
that is a hard guy to beat and he will always be ready.
That punch with junit or sons.
The first time I thought Ken was going to beat him exactly the way,
yes he did the second time because I thought,
oh,
he's going to outwork work him.
[inaudible] but junior never had anybody pressing as hard as Kane can do and
he's going to have work coming in a championship runs probably he might seal the
deal there.
But then he got hit with that also that the,
I mean you can't say take anything away from junior and it was a vicious
knockout striker,
cro,
cop out.
He talked to everybody for Dumas to everybody,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah.
He's an animal.
He really units that we're doomed.
Knockout.
It was brutal.
But the difference being that Cain Velasquez was injured in that fight.
I mean,
he had a pretty serious,
serious knee injury,
like he couldn't move and then you'll focus will be on that injury.
It's always like that.
Yeah.
So he,
he wasn't able to really,
uh,
you know,
like attack and have the,
the,
the mobility that he likes.
We mean,
the second fight was all about him moving forward and that's it.
Taking away the striking and it puts that pace on,
you know,
nobody could stop that.
You would know Matt Horwitz.
Right?
I mean,
he has almost no striking skills,
but he,
his stuff and he's got stamina,
you know,
and when he fought Mike Pyle,
I never forget this,
uh,
he beat my pile with a combination on the ground to the east Sacramento,
a submission,
which blew me away,
you know?
But he outworked him,
you know,
he's just got be tired.
And a later I overheard them talking and then a horse,
he says,
he's like freaking,
uh,
what is it,
rain man,
you know,
he,
he said,
yeah,
I know.
Yeah,
I know that you did.
You did it on four years ago.
I was rolling with you and you did that to me.
So I knew that was what the character was going to be.
He knew he rememberable four years ago.
He's a,
he's a strange cat.
Matt Hart,
she's a great guy to a beautiful,
he loves to cutting weight is fasting for him.
He says,
Oh,
I love to fans,
love the trees.
I love the university.
All of its potential possibilities in the multiverse,
like if you hear him tell,
I love this guy,
but he's a sweetheart of a guy and you're a very,
very tough guy too.
I mean,
and knocked out Benji radic but a headcase.
Crazy was that fun.
But again,
I was working and there are always these examples.
I always,
he makes the most the best.
Most technical fighters in the world makes him look like crap because why?
He can't take a punch and you just come forward and then you can be a great
striker.
You cannot strike moving backwards.
If you really push it,
you shut down the whole striking and that's how you find a great striker and
Matt Hall,
which is an interesting guy because he's not burdened down with ego.
I think a lot of guys with all their macho bullshit,
like you talk a lot of shit before a fight.
You carry that around with you like that,
that that becomes like a weight that you carry when you get inside that cage.
When you,
when you say,
I'm going to rip his head of his shit in his negative all day,
you know,
you know those kinds of things.
You have to understand that at the moment you have to go to the fight.
They play that clip on the big screen and you see yourself saying that and now
you're going to go,
I better do it and that's boom right away,
weight on your shoulders.
You should never do.
That's why I never did stare downs.
I don't like to get angry.
I don't want it to make,
I like to say little things in interviews that pissed him off.
So hopefully they get really angry at me like that a whole thing with chemo.
Leopoldo I never asked for him,
you know,
but they,
they,
they said that,
oh,
I went to the,
to the photo shoot for my last fight,
was that a WFA?
And he was there and I say,
Hey Kim,
how are you doing?
And he shook my hand and he looked right away your way.
And I go,
wow.
I go to Jeremy Lab.
And I said,
why he was taking this fights areas,
right?
And he says,
yeah,
we told him that she specifically asked for him.
I said,
why would you say that?
Well,
that gets him,
you know,
and it gets a little angry.
It's better for the fight.
And I go,
okay.
So I figured I'm not gonna say anything because then at least he will train very
art,
you know,
we're going to get a good fight.
But,
uh,
I always thought that I specifically asked for my,
I did a day,
they say,
well,
you want to fight.
I say Haitian and they say,
why?
I said,
well,
they always say he's the best.
So I would like to testify skellies and now we don't have the money for that.
I saw much money would've crossed for you to find Hixon Gracie.
Oh,
now how much would it back then?
I would,
for the same thing,
I would fired for to Hickson.
They said they couldn't afford them.
They said they couldn't.
Oh,
for him.
Okay.
Oh,
for me it was two 50 at the time.
How much would they pay Hicks?
How much did it?
I think a 6 million.
No subjects.
So I something high,
something.
I don't know.
But I heard really great.
You know,
whenever you read any of that,
we know better.
Don't believe it,
but no,
it really number.
But
I just thought,
you know,
I would love to because I have nothing.
You know,
each of the night we met in China,
everything's cool.
You know,
there's nothing going on because he is,
he's a really nice guy
who was talking about hoists.
Gracie won the very first UFC and hoists Gracie,
who's a brilliant Brazilian Jujitsu practitioner who really kind of expose
Brazilian Jujitsu to America and it showed it to a,
showcased it.
His brother was the champion of the family.
His brother,
apparently by all counts is the greatest Brazilian Jujitsu artists tower.
And everybody who rolls with them pretty much universally says this,
that Hickson has just on this other level.
So you,
you wanted to fight him,
Huh?
Just for that I write and even that will go into ground.
That would like,
because at that time I thought I chest,
well,
I just want to see you in Japan,
in pancreas when you won the king of Pancrase,
he had also won Japan valley too though.
Like within the year of that,
right.
He was sitting there when I was in the boot of gun,
knocked the guy out and,
and that was at a time when they were on the cover of black belt magazine saying
that up Andras this show.
I,
you know,
needless to say,
I say,
okay,
then I want to test the skills.
And that's,
uh,
that's where I actually challenged him.
I said,
hey,
I would like to fight you.
I don't mind the rules.
We will bend the rules.
Who will make any,
any real anytime.
And what happened,
you know,
and it never happens.
You know,
he tried to do it for pride.
Is that what you're trying to do with that?
What if bankwest was there?
But I said,
I don't mind any organization anywhere.
You know,
I left,
this fight happened and he didn't want me.
Once I put the fans to decide to,
to care about for fining,
you know,
if you really as a fighter,
go in fighting for yourself,
it doesn't really matter.
I always told my guys like this,
if it,
they put me with Randy couture in this room.
They looked the room and we fight.
It doesn't really matter who wins,
you know,
if he's better at that day,
he wins.
If I'm better,
I'm when,
you know,
it does.
But the what is hard for a fighters to come out and all these people know and
that Chris Leben said it very funny one time on our show.
He says he had,
the guy at blockbuster told me what I should have done when I fought Anderson
Silva,
you know,
and then I say,
yeah,
he's seen a lot of fighters care about that.
I always say the fight is what we say.
I fight for my family wrong,
right away.
Fight for yourself,
man for your fight.
A fight.
If you fight for yourself,
you fight the best.
If you really don't give a damn about anybody what they think you fight really
the best because it is not bad,
too loose.
You know,
everybody can have that day and that that's the mind set I had with the action.
You know?
Although I thought it was going to beat him,
but I would say,
you know,
it doesn't really matter.
This is testing the skill against somebody who everybody thinks is the best guy
in the world.
I would love to test that.
That was the only thing.
That was one of the things that Randy or we said that I,
I found a very admirable that he would say that to his fighters when they were
going out to fight.
He would say even if you lose,
if you lose the worst thing in the world,
you lose and you'll be fine.
You still have your friends,
you still have your loved ones.
Get that out of your head.
Don't worry about that.
Don't worry about losing because sometimes if you concentrate on not losing,
you can't see what you're doing.
You can't relax.
I say different.
I say as long as you fight,
yes,
you cannot lose.
You go to Japan.
I like a Vernon
tiger white,
one old boy lost a whole bunch fights in a row and it was a robot.
People waiting for him to get autographs and these people,
but he fought.
If you're under,
he's fan mentality is very different as well.
If you lay on the ground and somebody lifts his arm for granted potty you tab,
you'll never be back in Japan,
they'll boot you.
Then they got vicious,
you know,
and that's why I tell my students,
as long as you fight,
you know,
if you leave everything out there,
it doesn't matter if you want to lose it,
you know,
to me you can never loose.
Well also,
you're always,
you're always involved in improving yourself.
You're a work in progress.
And until you find those great fighters who are better than you,
you don't realize what you need to work on that uh,
God,
you show me a guy who,
you know,
I forget who made this quote,
but I put it on Twitter the other day.
I retweeted it yesterday.
Show me someone who hasn't made mistakes and I'll show you someone who hasn't
done anything.
Yeah.
And then that's,
it's true.
It's like you,
you,
you have to get beat in order to really understand that at first of all,
how much it sucks to lose and that will motivate you more.
The guys that are always problematic or the guys who are super talented that win
easy,
that don't have to train hard.
And then some day someone catches up to them and they,
and they lose if they lose.
It's always seminar.
You Watch,
they beat everybody into gym,
dominate everybody.
And once you fight on your own pace,
you never get tired.
You can fight for two hours.
But if you have that guy that push us and it stops your be interrupts your
breathing pattern.
That's what I always say.
You know,
that's the moment,
you know,
if somebody hits it back,
I'm standing behind him,
I'll kick him out of the blue to the body,
not to knock him out.
You know,
I had done that.
I do that.
So he has to flex at that particular moment and it interrupts his breathing
pattern and that's why you're getting tired,
you know?
I'm no kicking hard,
I'm just making him a bit,
oh,
does this.
And I always tell her,
you know,
he interrupted it and that's how you get diarrhea.
That's also the ratio with Nick Diaz.
Right?
With all his pat pat,
pat punches.
You never couldn't breathe.
He never got a chance to take a break and relax.
Yeah.
He's this guy who just flies to everything.
Now what do you think about that fight that's coming up this weekend?
Nick Diaz is fight and George St Pierre,
Johnny Hendricks is fight and Carlos condit and Jake Ellenberger is fighting a
Nate Marquardt,
assuming it's great fucking fights,
man.
That's going to be a really good show.
I,
it's a hard one.
You think if a GSP plays his game,
what do you normally does?
She's a really good restaurant.
We know he can take them down,
but the Nick Diaz to be underground,
he has to outwork him.
He needs to fight.
If he gets taken down to get back up and if he keeps fighting,
keeps fighting.
George gonna need a lot of,
spend,
a lot of energy,
you know it's going to be hometown for George.
A lot of pressure on his shoulders.
A lot of people don't want to.
Louis,
he knows so dead that he already,
that pressure may be already to care.
A little bit of a little bit of his stamina,
you know,
it took a little 20% of the way,
the motor pressure,
the more stamina get taken away from you.
You know,
he needs to be super,
super relaxed and if he doesn't let them to be super relax and constantly
escapes,
have fights,
the take down to fight back to get up,
you know,
then that might be a trouble for George.
But George was fighting last time because candid man,
I love that George.
That's,
that's the guy I want to see again,
a guy who he was working and he was working hard and that's what he needs to do
with Das,
but he needs to stay out of the garb.
Preferably,
I would say all have guards,
you know,
and,
and if you go into God,
whoa.
A squat,
don't let him close to guard.
That's going to be a problem for you constantly from half got squatted granum
pound,
uh,
playing the Jujitsu game on the ground.
I didn't know if it's a smart thing to do with the nick.
Yeah.
Nick has a hell of a guard.
New Southern.
The cyborg fight type.
Tap.
Cyborg.
The freaking collapsed on it.
Yeah,
the gummy fight.
Yeah.
He's,
uh,
he's very underrated I think.
I think he's got a,
he's got a lot of Brazilian jujitsu skills that we rarely see because over the
past couple of years he's been beaten guys up on the feet.
That's it.
And a,
and let,
now George has to overcome that,
reach that Longhand,
constantly peppering,
peppering them.
But I think he will shoot straight through it.
I think so,
yeah.
I think that Nate,
maybe if he would work really hard on any,
sorry nick and need to deface so on a take down because I think the take down
will be there anyway because he's such a good restaurant,
you know,
it's going to be hard to stop him.
But Kenny still stop him in the,
in the championship rounds.
If it goes in there,
you know.
Well,
and the question's gonna be,
well,
we'll,
is he going to try to stop him or is he going to try to pull guard?
Is he going to try to roll with it and just lock up a good position right away
like he did with Gomi or you know,
like he did with Cyborg.
He has a very nasty garden mean Nick Diaz is a high level black belt.
Yup.
And that fucking stamina,
man,
that's a big deal to,
that's the thing,
you know,
if you fight a guy like that,
um,
what,
what did they say?
They make scout with stem or fatigue makes cowards out of man.
And it really is real.
Been there,
you know,
that you're really tired.
I had it in a fight and I go,
oh my God,
I hope I did.
Thankfully I knocked him out with the needs of the liver,
but,
uh,
I was,
I was really about to stop almost,
you know,
and you,
you everything syncs away.
You know,
I was sick also,
but I mean it starts with seminar and fatigued and then when you see him still
going strong at some mental crusher man.
And uh,
and that's the thing that GSP now has.
He knows that whatever happens,
it's not going to run it against it.
Nick's not going to run against.
But you know what,
George has always been very,
very good condition as well,
you know?
Um,
it's,
it's interesting how many fighters get sick before fights.
It's a huge issue.
I always had it with the taekwondo days.
I'd get sick from the nerves,
but I think also a lot is the cutting weight.
Yes.
But it was also just hard training and not watching their diet.
And I never,
I never had that.
I brought my own food.
I brought my own loaf of bread and all that stuff.
I was not going to get food poisoning.
Forget about it.
I brought my own water.
You know,
you heard all these stories in Japan.
They say,
well,
something in your water.
I didn't want to take a risk of whether it's true or a myth or not.
I don't care.
I bring my own water,
nobody's going to touch it,
you know?
And,
uh,
at least I could have the dumbass thing.
And those are guys who go to day before,
go to
a Mcdonald's Sushi place somewhere,
you know,
and they're gonna eat like bad Sushi.
And they go,
yeah,
it's food poisoning.
You're an idiot.
That's part of your training.
You should not have done that.
Why take that risk?
Yeah.
It's the dumbest thing you can do.
It's like the guys were the mouthpiece,
you know?
But when I saw Karl appreciate five with the mouthpiece,
I fell out the whole time,
you know,
that drives me nuts.
That should be a penalty for that.
You know,
constantly fallout.
Like who does that?
You're a professional fighter.
You need a good mouthpiece,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
Do you,
are you still training fighters on a regular basis?
You know,
it's hard now because I have that neck surgery and uh,
last week I did two sets of pushups.
Uh,
18 imagine I did the 124 fun begging the day and uh,
so,
and I was like,
Oh my God,
I'm so weak.
And then after two days I lost all power.
So I know there is something that when it swells up or the flares up,
it stops my nurse from getting in a day.
Tomorrow I'm going to find out two more,
10 45 in the morning going to find out they didn't have the nerve conduction
test where that marketers,
and I think once they can open that up,
then everything's going to be just so you're going to have to have another
operation.
I don't know,
maybe they say,
oh,
well it's rest or this or maybe they do an epidural there right on the spot that
will loosen it up,
something like that.
But,
uh,
my nerve in my neck jumped from under low 30%.
He said when we opened your neck,
a jumped back,
same level of shadow 100 was been dealing with this for years,
years now.
It's a nightmare.
But you know,
I used to be a crazy guy training I,
I scan of my own stuff,
you know,
because I was talking to people,
a world champions,
and it would teach,
what did they say?
They go hard on Fridays,
70% and I go,
and what do you do for the rest of what we train?
I said,
you're spar one day a week.
Yeah.
And I started laughing.
I said,
but I say I sparked two times a day.
W W we go heart,
I'll try to knock your idea legs or your buddy or you do it to me.
And on the hat,
of course I'm not going to knock him out,
but I got guys,
I've got to control for that.
But we go,
we go.
Right.
You know,
I,
that's why I never had a ring rust when I came back in 2006.
You know,
I didn't fight for six years,
but I had no problem because two times a day we have a fight.
That's what we're doing.
So I felt great.
Then what about the wear and tear though from doing that?
That's the thing.
That's the thing,
uh,
advice to every fighter now is to always get the right equipment,
make sure you're packed him and make sure your ankles or tape,
things like that.
Because with the Shin protection now they got really good Shin protection that
has also,
you know what the instep,
they have protection there now,
you know,
so that cannot be hurt.
Like when you kick an elbow.
Right.
And those are bad injuries the whole time.
You know,
watch out.
Just just back yourself and make a good mouthpiece.
Get a professional mouthpiece done.
Right.
It's a put grease on your way down.
Watch for cuts.
I play everything safe.
Now when you have God's training though,
do you have them spa that same way twice a day,
you know,
going all out.
We have people coming in us and it went as
far on Sundays and they turned around when they seem spar they go like,
but that's,
that started since Carlo Rommel deck cause his brother came to teach at my gym.
He says now we're going to support like we do in Holland and now that's,
that's the way we used to do it.
And they go hard and got going on down.
Yeah.
All the,
all the guys are guys are already used to it.
Wow.
They just don't care.
They just go.
But,
but to get the right equipment,
as long as you have the right equipment that you don't get me.
No.
Where is your ra?
Your gyms in thousand oaks,
right?
Yeah.
It's a on Hampshire road.
Eight,
eight Zero Hampshire rooted the website.
If people want to get some information about that elite MMA gym.com and a,
so you have a Ramon Dekkers brothers teaching down there.
He's teaching dare.
Yeah,
like low,
long time in a busy,
been there for his whole career teachers,
all those whole to focus and tie pads for all the top guys.
Ovary Peter Earth.
Versace,
I mean,
all these guys have been there,
you know,
so he's a,
yeah,
a really great guy.
What is his name?
Carlo Carlo deckers.
Carla deckers.
Wow.
And when is he there with Dave?
Well,
he's there every day and now we should,
of course she's still had hold because the funeral of us a couple of days ago
and uh,
I didn't even ask him.
I told him,
you know,
take whatever time you need and uh,
to wrap things up there because he was very close to her Monday.
We're like,
uh,
yeah,
two peas in department there was very hard for us.
Crazy.
He had a heart attack riding a bike.
I mean,
thinking about all the fights that guy had and also,
you know,
yeah,
we're talking about two or the 45 days or something.
You know,
this guy,
it's fighting with a broken hand and the broken foot at the same time.
And it would keep fighting,
you know,
the guy was just in and also living at clean,
healthy lifestyle now for the last six years or so.
You know,
like,
uh,
being in shape,
you don't have everything planned out.
He has this child for children's foundation that he set up in Thailand for these
kids who,
you know,
who had no future and he would give them money and all that stuff is now,
still going to happen to us now t shirts coming and may bloodlines is going to
make a t shirt 100% goes to the family or to the charity.
So they're working on a lot of things to keep his name out there.
Of course it's fucked up.
I can just be that great a fighter and athlete and just have a heart attack at
43 and just dropped dead.
It's a wireless thing ever.
You know,
I uh,
since uh,
he passed away.
I drank one and a half glass of wine.
[inaudible] normally I drink two classes at night or to draw,
maybe I right away I go,
oh my God,
this is really scary.
He was healthy.
He was good.
There was nothing in his family who,
you know,
bad hearts,
nothing just out of the blue.
So,
uh,
that really freaked me out.
Yeah.
Well it's gotta be freaking you out with all this nerve shit going on with your
bonding.
Yeah.
Once his comes back,
you know,
I,
I've been always blessed with all the kind of stuff.
I grew up,
it,
it heals fast.
And I think it comes because of my,
my,
uh,
Eczema that I had really bad asthma.
So I was recouping fast by like my,
if I had one said training,
like a wound that would be literally today,
she couldn't tell her what it was.
There we go so fast because that was what my skin was doing 24,
seven,
you know,
so now it's,
I'm blessed with having that,
but my neck,
that's annoying.
That doesn't really,
you know,
spike those blockages.
It's here.
I can feel it.
It's,
it's the lumps.
And what is a blockage?
Is it scar tissue and muscle spasms?
What they say?
What stops the nerves from getting in my arm?
And that's why I look,
it's all thin.
It doesn't fill up yet yet.
It will start happening.
And they said because of what you've done by,
by fusing the neck,
it's alleviated.
Some of the pressure is I jumped back right away to 100% this is what they said.
So curbing to me.
How many people have back issues?
I mean it's so disturbing.
There's so many guys were fucked up backs.
It's really crazy,
man.
My Shit's fucked up right now.
But it's just because I got three myths sizes in one day,
which never do that ever.
Well that's a sore.
You just,
you're talking about muscles,
you know the,
the,
the issue that these fighters are having is a lot different than you pal.
Yeah.
The um,
the wear and tear on the body's just fucking unbelievable.
It's brutal.
You look at it,
no time to recoup all show.
You know,
I had,
when I was preparing for that last fight,
I had two times a week off.
I had only 10 weeks for that fight.
I didn't train for three years.
So I have 10 weeks to get a shape and two weeks from that I didn't,
he didn't train at all for three years.
No,
not at all.
I,
since my last fight,
I think I worked out maybe 25 times.
That's in 2006 wow.
Yeah,
that's mad that that will be at the end because I started finally I started
training again and then my God,
I feel really good.
Like if four weeks I was actually,
people always think that I just say something and that it's not too,
I say the boss,
the body actually system,
I use that myself,
the o two trade,
I use it myself to workout shoes myself and they go,
yeah,
you're just saying that.
I go,
wait a minute,
I can go back on my security camera and you can actually see me training in the
backyard.
So I went back on a security camera and I got it for a month back and I was
trading only for five fixed and at the beginning you see me,
I'm struggling man.
I'd like two minute vine.
It's really bad.
But the amazing,
if you see like several workouts further,
it's a whole different,
suddenly the screen for the auto trader and went from three til seven which is a
heavy setting already at 10 pound ankle weights,
heavy gloves.
I put weights in there also hitting and then one day,
yeah.
Yeah,
but I watch out with our hyper extending.
Then when I do that,
you know,
or I hit that boss thing so you don't don't hyper extend but it's good for the
burn and for everything.
You get tired and then I,
I threw one time in the air,
something I think I maybe I hyper extended and the West just for one day to get
out of my head dropped and I go,
Oh God,
it's back and it was it.
That was in October and then they did the surgery in the January but we're
getting yourself back in shape.
I was and it was good and really well I start feeling great already.
I mean you,
you watch,
it's online.
It's on the Ode to train in the O two trainer blog.com you can find the video
there and your neck.
When the first operation they didn't fuse the discs would they do,
they made the holes around the nerves a little,
but it was still
a little squeezing so it was only a 30% working in.
I knew that because herniated discs,
is that what it was?
But they only worked like 30% or a little bit less and I knew that because I
could like with with 10 pounds,
he did like 25 reps.
Still very weak because I used to do way more with that.
But that makes sense.
With the 25 of the 30% I go okay.
But then when it happened in the training,
I think something disk,
that's when the the judge jam habit here.
Now knowing what you know and are all
this experience that you have,
especially all this experience where your body like breaking down,
what,
what do you tell finders to do now?
I mean do you,
what do you,
what do you advise them?
How do you not do what you did?
That was wrong.
Stretch,
stretch man.
Stretch a lot.
I would stretch.
I will make that one of my primary things,
you know,
watching TV,
just stretch while you're watching TV,
get to stretch bands,
do you know?
Yeah.
While you're watching TV,
you're busy with it doesn't really matter and,
and good food don't dehydrate yourself or why she started the hydrating
yourself.
Stretch even more men because that's where you,
your tendons get dehydrated.
Everything there they ripped faster than she is.
See a lot of that also happened close to a fight.
They study hydrating and to make it kick and they pull a hamstring,
you know,
that's exactly because of that reason.
You're dehydrating yourself.
Those tenants need to stay moist,
you know,
make,
keep it good and watch out.
And as far as
like,
what kind of therapy that you're doing right now for,
for your,
for your back,
do you do any inversion therapy or any,
uh,
nothing?
Were there,
uh,
trying to do any sort of traction?
No.
I,
what I do,
I have to two to a hook,
so to say,
well in my hand and I have to understand to go to the second floor with this,
uh,
hang,
hang.
I just hang in a stretch my arms out and that seems to help.
Like last week I could do three,
uh,
with five pounds,
three reps,
five pounds.
Wow.
And,
and then I started stretching and I start mentally focusing.
Somebody told me just force it to be gone and the official,
I visualize how you could get rid of it.
And I started doing that and then yesterday evening at a 10,
so,
and that was just in,
in four days.
But I've been also hanging.
How many of the guys you run into then have these issues get lots.
A lot of guys have the Benji radic Tito Ortiz issue as well.
Yeah.
The big nick also lost,
stuck or lost everything.
He lost this pack.
So I believe that's a c seven or eight or something.
I think I'd,
I,
I dunno how did it at sex works with me.
It's a biceps,
biceps,
the shoulder,
my shoulder starts coming back now because that there,
of course over here,
over the top.
That's good start.
I see the muscle started getting there,
so that's good.
But the for the biceps and I get this,
uh,
carpal tunnel that I already had but never was a problem with me.
But now because the nerve,
it is a problem.
So now I can't,
if I grab things from a whole Hanse spasms,
you know,
it's really weird before demonstrations and I always say,
Gosh,
should she,
that it's not like I'm not crazy.
It's just my hand shoot suddenly like that.
And I like when I grab something,
I starts,
it's really weird when my wife started noticing,
because I was sitting like this the whole time,
he says,
what is,
what would you hands?
And they get it Greek.
You can open it up.
Yup.
Wow.
That's gonna be like for a dude is this bad motherfucker former UFC champion.
That's got to be really like disturbing.
It is.
It is really the serving.
I don't like to see myself as weak.
I started to biking now because I can do with my knees now.
You know,
I'm actually going to get a nicer bike now show I got to because of the issues
as well.
Oh yeah.
I have no cartilage in my knee caps and there's nothing they can do for that.
Now I know,
I know everybody's got an email.
Oh,
I notice doctor.
No,
if you go to a real surgeon,
they will tell you there's nothing they can do when you have no car show.
And he kept the only thing they cannot fix,
actually al trash at the colon joke told me that's the reason why the mafioso is
break your meat kneecaps.
It's inflexible.
He can't.
And uh,
the bolt now if had patches out,
they can regrow my own cartilage that you get older to have a stem cells and
they get,
and that grows itself.
Like if they,
they explained like Ma,
uh,
a matter of grass when pieces are out,
she put pieces of grass it there.
And that goes with the undergrads and it's strong.
Again,
that's how cartilage works.
He says,
but if you have none,
there's no way they can attach it to your kneecap.
Now there is something they can do.
They have to drill a hole and attention and a Teflon plate,
which will work.
But then unique emas 35% weaker,
more chance of breaking and when some breaks you're really done,
you know.
So he said,
well will come,
they will find something in a couple of years.
But right now walking stairs,
getting up,
sitting down,
up or down,
walking,
everything hurts and everything.
My friend Steve has his knees,
he was on the US ski team.
He's had like,
I dunno,
some insane amount of knee surgeries,
more than 20 knee surgeries as well.
Yeah.
And he has the,
he had no cartilage in his needs as well.
And he's got these steel plates that are over the tops of his,
uh,
his joint.
Like we're where the cartilage used to be.
They resurfaced it.
Yeah.
What they do,
they go with lasers in and then it bleeds out.
Right.
Or they can do that too.
But with me,
the kneecap,
like with you there,
they're standing on each other.
Those that said the kneecap,
when I stretch my leg and I bended,
it already moved again.
So whatever they attach it,
it's in constant motion.
You can't do anything like between the knees,
between your upper leg,
your lower leg.
Yeah.
Their stuff that they can put in between and we surface and they do that.
Uh,
what is it?
They let you bleed.
They let you bleed your own blood.
You know,
the nobody lets me bleed my own blood.
A movie,
whether it again,
dodge ball or something then yeah,
but they drill these holes in the knees and it starts bleeding and that serves
all like that.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's a scenes knee.
That's where you see that.
But I can see what a kneecap goes through.
I can't tell that everybody,
I don't want to go on top,
but the kneecap,
it's,
you know,
maybe on that other stuff I can,
I can put something like that on the other bones.
Not at an ECAP will that is his kneecap?
Yeah.
One piece.
I got all three.
Yeah.
Well that's the bottom piece.
And then the top piece and where,
where the cartilage used to be.
Look at this,
Brian,
have you seen it?
Where did he do with this?
Well,
Steve's a at the cutting edge because he's a doctor himself,
so he's well aware of what I need his number.
See that's a,
he just popped the thing out that's um,
for the folks at home can see it.
He's a,
he's happy with it.
Also you can see lower as I scroll down a bit,
you see that white thing?
That white thing is a artificial meniscus.
So he's got the double,
he's got a double whammy.
He's got a resurface knee.
So the top of his bone is covered with this steel plate.
And uh,
then he also has this white stuff here,
which is a,
an artificial meniscus pad.
I,
yeah,
I'm still trains.
I need his information.
That's for real.
I love to do that man.
My knee sometimes when they shoot me up a cortisone shot,
then for like two and a half weeks,
it is paradise for me.
Like I can't walk stairs.
I can jump,
I can jump up from happiness.
Ooh.
I don't feel a thing.
It's amazing the difference.
How,
what did you do to fucked up all,
you're a unique Harland.
I'm just very explosive and I think that just crushed everything.
I'm,
wow,
I'm blah,
I'm kicking,
kicking,
drilling.
I was in cakes to do it.
Right.
You know,
during the pain.
Just go through it,
you know?
And if it's Banco harder,
that's the mentality.
Right.
That's the only way I got to go through it.
When you,
now that you've done that all though and you seen like what,
what that damage can do to your body,
whatever,
you know,
I regret everything.
I go like,
why did I do it so crazy?
But now again,
when I see fighters go fulltime and I go,
sometimes I go,
wow,
it's weird.
I did all that.
You know that you'll,
you look crazier back at life after you're out of it.
Yeah.
It's definitely way I never had though.
It comes show for people go like,
oh look at him,
but it's really not.
I never was nervous like that.
I was really good at talking to myself.
I did everything that in my life.
When I went through,
I realized it was all meditation.
I never taught,
everybody taught me anything,
but I'm just really talking to myself.
What's the worst thing that can happen?
Well,
you know the worst thing that can happen and you knock out,
you're not going to feel it.
Okay.
Can we get submitted Julia tap and it's over.
It's the people talking.
That's the worst thing that really,
if you're think about it,
people talking shit.
Yeah.
So,
and since I don't care about that,
I wouldn't have known there was four wheel and I would always in that zone.
I would,
I was addicted to that feeling going there and go.
And then I would hear,
I would hear,
I would tell people's conversations at the first row after us,
I will go back.
I said,
I heard you talking about the movie yesterday evening.
All right,
so,
but Mari Smith's,
I was going to give the go Soka high cake and my,
I'm,
I'm always listening to it,
the other corner and he goes,
watch out for the high kick.
I right away.
So I switched for a straight punch and the dogs also Japan,
right,
where they're really quiet.
And the yard there was here in America I guess,
cause it was the UFC,
my first UFC she fight.
Oh,
Calsa Casa.
Okay.
Yeah.
And then Maury Smith was saying,
yeah,
because he saw me setting it up and then so I changed this writer.
I switched it to a straight punch because I heard him and I told him,
I say,
you should be quiet.
He says,
bus,
you're probably the only goal is that he had to go in it,
you know?
But I used to always do it again in French shamrocks blood,
uh,
blood book.
It's so funny to read.
He says,
yeah,
bus was always talking,
you know,
I think you kind of did it,
to,
to self meditation.
But then I say,
okay,
why do you think I are?
I have a Dutch Garner.
Why do you think are stocking English speaking English?
I did it for a reason.
If I do it in Dutch,
they're not going to understand what I'm saying.
But if I'm in the middle of a fight,
look at my corner.
I say,
do you want to go to Rebekah tonight?
What do you want to go more down tonight?
Yeah.
Okay,
let's go.
What are you going to drink?
You know,
I would just do some crazy stuff and then they would continue fighting and those
fighters who go like,
what the hell is that?
It was a distraction.
It's just a distraction.
And I will do it in English because otherwise dodgy couldn't understand.
So that's why I spoke English.
When you put together this gym out in thousand oaks,
it's a,
you know,
you've got a really nice place.
It's very nice.
Were you,
um,
were you thinking about starting a team and,
and,
and training fighters and moving onto the next phase?
No,
no,
no.
For me it's just a good place that I can go and train.
I could still teach.
I almost,
I'm,
I'm pretty much almost all the time,
they're on Tuesdays and Thursday.
The teachers,
six o'clock myself for the general audience.
But it also approached,
been coming in because I go back to the basics and basics is effort of all the
magic happens.
Man.
They trust me in a lot of pros,
forget it or,
or their teachers don't want to say it anymore because now he's signed again,
that really high level and I don't care where you are,
I'm just going to tell you this is what you do wrong.
You can hit harder if you do it like this,
try it out.
And only most of the time to try it out they go,
oh my God,
I hit much harder.
He,
she,
they just forget certain things and I like to put them back on the basics and I
liked it to have a gym at my name is very close to my house,
you know,
and I can actually be there Sunday morning.
She know I'm going to start doing now more.
I got to,
to the fight classes with the guys just to enjoy that.
I have a really good partner.
You know who,
uh,
thankfully he helped me out a lot because without him we could have not been
open,
uh,
because we lost a lot of money to make the gym.
But now we're at a place like the last half year.
We started finally to make money and that's,
that's of two years being here,
six years at the other place.
So the ags,
we never made any money.
We were broke even at the other place.
And this is a eight and a half thousand square foot place.
You got Sauna as we,
I mean it's a really nice place and people love it,
you know,
and to find the thing that we have,
we have 30 people sign up,
say a month,
a five stay and those 25 there are all these tough guys that come in and be
their bodies saying,
man,
you can do that shit.
You know,
you got to do it.
I really look at that.
They make a lot of money.
So then they come in and they get beat up by blue belts,
you know,
little kids and that's it.
That's [inaudible] program there as well.
Yeah.
I got to hold Rigo cuff.
Otto,
he was a world champion last year at the Gracies cause six weeks.
She told me this morning he's got to go another gun.
And in Long Beach.
He's unbelievable.
He came in was five days in the country and he wants to,
he told me,
hey bars,
the naga championships are in a vigorous,
you think I should go?
I say,
you're thinking you can do it?
He said,
yeah.
I said,
but you didn't train.
He said,
no,
I want to do it.
I said,
oh well we'll drive you over there.
So brought him and he won gold right away.
And then he won the one at the Gracie.
He won gold again.
So it's a very,
very high level that guy.
Cause he teach.
Yeah,
both.
And he is,
I've never had one complaint from him,
you know,
a,
sorry,
you got to do with five classes more because we're not pulling it now.
Right now I have no problem.
Boom.
Right away.
You know,
he's the light.
The best,
best.
Then we have everybody,
all the parents for kids and everybody's telling me,
my God is such a great guy.
So teach kids classes.
Each class is awesome.
One of the kid classes,
uh,
at four o'clock.
Most of the time.
Yeah.
Four o'clock on Saturdays that I believe at noon from,
no,
that's great.
And thousand oaks where you're at as an awesome spot.
It's beautiful.
It's really nice.
So quiet.
You'll be,
yeah,
no,
it's,
when we arrived there,
we made the turn on mostly boulevard.
I saw the promenade there with,
you know,
there was a band playing and Friday night they're worse.
I go,
wow,
we want to live here.
You know,
no parking meters,
no nothing.
You know,
it's a nice place.
Best school system,
like blue ribbon schools all around,
you know,
it's,
it's cool for the kids.
Safe second safest city in the country.
You know,
the other one has Irvine,
Irvine.
Irvine is like the safest city in the country.
See Irvine is very,
very safe.
It's all white people.
Yeah.
If I,
if I was a criminal,
you've of course it all the garage doors.
My friends,
he had a $6,000 bike and leaves the garage door and we always said,
you know,
you got to close the garage.
Sure enough,
they stole his bike and thousand oaks thousand oaks,
they say,
but that's,
that's the smarter criminal goes to those places because everybody or you don't
have to lock your doors,
you know,
because it says safe.
That's why it got robbed in Burbank that said sketchy.
Sketchy.
Yeah.
To banks.
Very close to a lot of funky areas.
Know thousand oaks in the middle of fucking nowhere.
Sure.
Yeah.
Nobody wants to go there,
you know?
But then once you're there,
it's,
they call it pilot town because the pilots would see from the top that there was
no pollution there.
That's how it got started with all pilots living there.
And then it becomes an oh yeah,
yeah.
Oh,
that's interesting.
And then it became a,
because they say,
oh,
it's the valley.
I said,
dude,
we're 50 miles out of the valley.
We were like far away from it.
But that's,
it's like 40 degrees,
lower temperature.
The temperature wise then the valley has,
yeah.
You get that breeze from the ocean too.
I feel like the further you can get away from La,
the better you are at.
There's too many fucking people here.
The other day,
Saturday in the afternoon.
Okay.
I,
uh,
drove down to meet a friend of mine and Bellflower,
so I drove down.
It took me two hours to get there in two and a half hours to get back on a
Saturday.
Yeah.
Bumper to bumper traffic stopped dead on the one 34 stopped dead on the four oh
five,
I switched to two 10 stopped dead.
It was fucking nuts.
The one a one stop dead.
The five stop dead everywhere on Saturday.
Like what happens if
the shit hits the fan?
That's why I always save all my telephone calls.
I saved there for one day.
If I,
for instance,
have to go to San Diego,
that's where all my phone calls start happening because I save up for that time,
the two and a half hours on the world or whatever it is,
maybe three hours of just traffic and then I make all the phone calls,
phone calls to do it at the same time.
You know what?
I do bus route and I listen to audible.com audible.com yeah.
Yeah.
This Fox again.
Is that what the commercial is?
Not Commercial.
I do though.
It's amazing.
It's great.
Audible books.
Audio books are amazing.
Oh,
you know I love on Hln they have the HSA crime cases.
I love that.
You know,
and then the men walked in but he forgot one thing.
One thing that left one another thing on the,
on the road.
Oh yeah.
Mysterious is on Hln.
I don't know.
Tell and HLN headline news from CNN and I guess it is or something.
Also satellite,
satellite radio and then you got those,
those great things.
But are there things,
you know watching the Jody area escape?
Oh my God.
That if she gets out,
that's like the weirdest thing to total psycho.
Once I go,
I mean she goes head to head with the,
with the prosecutor and then when she thinks she has the best of him,
she like chuckles it.
Okay,
I got you.
I go,
dude.
Yeah,
people are watching you.
You know,
you'll see they see it.
Yeah.
If you don't know that story,
she stabbed the guy,
cut his head,
shot him,
and then shut up.
She did a bunch of fucked up,
but does she goes to the problem because she said she shot him first,
but now all the blood was there and the shell casing was on top of the blood.
So she shot him.
She killed him for snap them into back crazy.
Yeah.
And had rented a special car.
They wanted to give her a red car.
She says,
no,
I want to a wide one because she didn't want to attract attention,
you know,
uh,
three cans of gasoline.
So she didn't have to stop anywhere so she could be traced back.
I mean,
it was the wildest thing that a 22 gun,
which happened to be the murder weapon the day before she left,
very mysteriously disappeared from her grandparents.
Where she,
by the way lives,
you're locked into this story.
Oh,
I don't,
yeah,
this is on.
It's amazing.
Isn't it fucked up when you see someone whose life just went completely off the
rails.
When you see someone crazy like that,
just one day wax out and just stabbed somebody and shoot some.
And this one,
you know,
she was like three months away from him and that she was still following him.
He did things on stage,
whatever I was public speaking or something.
She would like make pictures and she would tell people,
isn't the beautiful,
is it be while they already separated?
I go,
yeah,
that's,
yeah.
Well,
dot guy.
Fuck the shit of that bed.
That's
part of what happened there.
That kind of broker that she did some,
that was the reason to her,
oh,
everything.
He did everything well,
but now she tried to give it to say he's a pedophile,
you know?
And it's like what I mean,
drags is to the month poor guy,
you know,
he's already done.
Yeah.
But just Paris has already done the worst.
I know.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
The um,
they sent my friend Tony Zara,
I remember Tony,
a turtle from,
uh,
Columbus.
He has a great saying that I say all the time,
it said a psychotic and erotic or very close to each other.
Oh yeah,
we're very close to each other.
And those really crazy girls are oftentimes the best in bed.
So nutty.
And the shit they'll do is so crazy.
So this fucking guy,
I mean you listen to some of the text messages that he was sending her.
You know,
you're my dirty little whore,
Joanie and porn movies.
Like people write like that.
Oh,
this fucking check his text messages.
I'll send you something.
He'll forward you.
Yeah.
Thank you.
So polite.
There's a lot of nutty people out there,
man.
There's a lot of them.
Fucking nutty people.
Very crazy people.
I showed in my wife,
uh,
Dick Karate.
I
did karate guy story,
the street karate guy.
What happened?
Oh,
this is a funny story.
Okay.
We're at,
um,
at um,
Kimbo has to fight and um,
before the fight we go to a tap out party and those people are there.
And then the guys,
he stuff guys that they're one of us,
I think selling jewelry or something and he was with a bunch of guys and from
the guys,
I think he was the toughest guy.
So,
um,
we're talking and of course he didn't know who I was,
so that was the best thing.
And that people were talking about finding it.
Suddenly he comes to fourth and he goes,
yeah,
I used to do a karate.
He says,
but not a normal cardiac is to do street karate.
I go,
wow,
street karate was so,
what is that?
He said,
well,
I can tell you one thing that my routine has saved me like six,
seven times.
And I go,
your routine.
Yeah,
I got,
okay,
you got to show me that routine.
And you know,
because I would,
I would love to learn.
So the guy comes to me and I actually put this in the movie,
here comes the boom.
You know,
that was a true story.
I and I,
well,
there's a long story,
but anyway,
so the guy comes to me,
he says,
first of all,
I would stand there and then out of the blue I will go,
no,
no.
He got his goes first with his elbow.
He coach to me,
he does it to me,
disclose,
right and blah.
And then he goes,
and he was shaking in front of my face.
He's serious,
he's serious.
He's this close to my face,
right?
Shaking like this loss and my friends,
everybody is already like almost dying,
laughing.
And then he says,
and then a moment he's perplexed by and I go,
I go to the neck.
And then he,
oh,
they always do this.
She said,
it says in there,
grab him.
And now he kept eye contact with me,
right?
And he grabbed,
she says,
God.
So he threw knees to the body throughout grounds,
stopped contact with me and he stops,
you know,
okay.
So I look at him,
I go,
okay,
Nah,
you never did that.
Total bullshit.
I said,
you practiced this in the mirror and it looks really cool,
but you never did this.
He know know his friends were like,
they were waiting for my reaction because they were in awe.
You know,
this,
this guy was,
it was his glory.
And then when at the moment I said,
total bullshit.
I started talking and there's not a guy came and she know who he is.
He always actually professional fighter.
So the whole group left,
but the fact the deface the facial expression from all those guys to all dressed
the same,
like do you Scacchi switch shirts over the top?
All jewelry everywhere.
You know the,
those guys,
exactly.
The streets karate guy,
his routine saved his life seven times,
you know,
and they tell me that you believe that crap.
It was the most insane thing I've ever seen and I did.
And here comes the boom you've ever had,
but need to deface throwaway stub.
Right?
Victory Dance.
You know,
and I that I told that the backstage camera for hit goes to them.
I said,
this is a true story.
Somebody told me this thing,
nick,
there's a lot of those knuckleheads,
right?
Those street defense guys,
they're like fake karate guys.
And you know,
the worst part is they say,
yeah,
we cannot use it in the ring because it's way too dangerous.
Yeah.
I said,
well,
if you could kill somebody like this,
she can also not kill him.
Yeah.
Right.
I mean,
what,
yeah,
like that kind of control control.
You've just,
uh,
the techniques are too lethal boss.
You don't understand.
They're like,
it's like dropping a nuclear explosion on you.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
The one in spine shoulder,
uh,
yeah.
I love those videos.
Like [inaudible] videos,
the guys at demonstrating techniques and how they're going to work.
And have you seen the one where the old man who's got this a class where he
throws like people and then a karate Guy Pankratz guy comes in and beats the
shit out of me,
the shit out of her bed.
And then you see him bleed.
He's,
he's seeing himself.
He cannot believe it.
It doesn't work.
It's drying.
The one guy,
he does ticket ticket ticket,
the guy goes,
yeah,
he goes and he makes a somersault and he falls on the ground.
It's almost like he believed his own bullshit.
Right.
What are these guys doing?
They're all faking it.
They know they are,
but they're probably,
it's like mass hypnosis or mass hysteria,
you know,
like cult behavior.
They get locked into believing.
Like I remember when I was in,
um,
my taekwondo school was not like cultish in the sense,
like they,
nobody had to do anything crazy.
They didn't try to get your money or get you to leave your family or anything
like that,
but the devotion that some people had towards the instructor was a pretty crazy,
it's amazing and they didn't exploit it,
but if someone did exploited,
you could see how they could get some weak people that would really fall into
it.
It's,
it's sort of a disturbing aspect of martial arts that I went to.
One of the things that I really loved about Brazilian Jujitsu was that you kind
of see that you didn't see like all the Bowery.
It was more like friendly.
Like when I trained with the Machados like,
hey my friend,
how are you?
And it was much once they show you the techniques,
but they're very friendly and more,
more like,
like,
you know,
they don't try to place themselves above anyone.
There's no master this because they're going to let you know that it is really
effective right there and there on the respect that you get from them.
You'll,
they'll earn interest by being amazing,
but it's because they're good.
All the other guys who preach and talk about it like that,
they're not good.
They suck.
Like every guy who tells me that he is unbelievable,
but he never fought.
Yeah.
It's full of Shit.
Well,
you know how many times you told me you indeed it's not.
It's not possible.
You never,
he will not know.
If he can do it under pressure.
He will not.
It's amazing.
Do you know when you guys have told me though that they could never lose?
I never lose me.
You don't know about my mentality.
I'm in.
Paladin gets choked.
I'm like an animal,
Bro.
I'm a go.
Why am I go blank and then drop it?
I go blank.
Get a means.
You're going to think right.
That's the easiest.
I hit named Jess coming into my class one time.
I,
I'm no kidding.
There's a guy walking in with the stash glasses and a big belly and it Blue Blue
Kimono and it came in my NGO in Holland and he walked in.
There was six girls following him.
It was like a cult.
It was the weirdest thing ever.
Later on we find out he couldn't even like eight pushups.
It was like bizarre.
And every time when I would show something,
they would say something like one time,
you know,
uh,
I had an arm bar and this girl says,
oh,
we would buy it in the leg,
you know,
so I started slowly but surely I figure I'm not going to say anything,
but then you know,
it kept going,
kept going and have somebody in a rear naked choke and I said,
it's not going to have an explaining as she goes to somebody else.
She said,
we were buggy.
I said No.
And I go,
oh,
excuse me,
what was there?
And she said,
we,
we will poke your eyes out right now.
I said,
wow,
let's find out.
I mean,
I'm going to try this with you.
Is that cool?
Yeah.
She goes,
I just got to sit down.
I said,
put my arm around her neck.
okay.
In three,
six I'm going to go,
if you've touched my,
I'm going to break your neck.
Okay,
let's go.
She goes,
well,
what,
what did she say?
I said,
in three seconds we're going to go and we'll count down.
You come near to my fucking,
I'm going to break your neck.
Okay,
I should've done,
what do you,
what do you mean?
I said,
okay.
You know,
normally when somebody touched my eye,
you think I'm going to go,
oh no,
I'm going to go to the top of my idol and I'm going to go.
Then my eye hurts.
That face was awesome.
Never,
never fuck with somebody who has a dominant position over you.
If I have you in an arm bar and you buy my calf,
guess what's going to break at that moment is the most idiot thing that people
actually believe that if you put a finger in my Ivan a lab life and death
situation,
I'm going to let go of the choke.
Yeah,
really?
You know I'm going to snap the neck first and I'm going to let go to church.
Well,
not only people don't understand
how quick you go.
Unconscious like,
well,
if someone has a rear naked choke on you,
especially if you don't really know defense.
He haven't been choked a lot before.
You don't know how to relax.
You don't have,
oh,
and do you know all hard it is to poke and eye.
Yeah,
it's fucking hard.
Very hard.
It's very hard to squeeze my,
I put my,
my I against your,
the back of your neck,
back of your head.
Well,
you used to doing boss Wooten is fighting in a sport type situation where you've
got rules.
See out in the street there are no rules,
you know,
and like,
I cannot fight without rules to,
it's like,
I guess that by still only I can do it better,
more accurate as well.
I,
I used to do this,
I do this radio show,
I won't name the guy,
but there was a guy that they had as their body guard and he's a fucking total
bullshit artist.
And he was fucking dude with videos doing nunchucks and shit.
It was so stupid bastard.
So opie and Anthony Show and we were on the show once and this,
I mean I'm fine,
you know,
you,
you do whatever you want,
but as soon as you're on the air and you represent it,
you know,
I gotta,
I gotta tell the truth.
You're on the fucking radio now and people are gonna listen to you.
And if I let you get away with some nonsense and not,
not me,
man,
some young kid could it be listening to that and they want to start a martial
art and they get sucked into doing a stupid fucking creek street karate classes.
Cause I go,
listen,
it's a real simple,
the shit that works on trained killers is the best shit.
Yeah.
You don't see Anderson Silva,
you know,
practicing I pokes and fuck.
Although I pokes a pretty fucking,
they've worked.
Maybe you don't see him doing the,
you know,
a death touch and fucking,
pressure point attacks.
That shit doesn't work.
I said on,
on,
on camera,
we had an email from somebody who said,
um,
that his monster could,
but point pressure state they could knock you out.
I got a great story,
but it does also with the mirror.
Anyway,
I'd looked into gamma.
I said,
okay,
anybody in America you're watching right now,
if you have a person who gets,
who says that he can knock me out with a punch like it just pressing somewhere.
We invite him,
we pay him,
we pay his trip,
he can come on the show,
he can do it on camera on me.
He can knock me out.
I said it's a no lose situation for me because if it works,
I'm signing up.
I'm going to do that stuff.
But I tell you it's not going to work.
We had this guy with a,
you know a mirror Pareto,
you know [inaudible] my buddy.
We see these guys on stage and the touch guys,
right?
So one guy goes this,
this was the person who says they just fall back and then the guy said,
did you see his eyes roll back in his skull?
That means he was out for real.
So I'd go to America.
This is going to be fun.
Why is this so these guys,
they come walking down after the session.
I said,
okay,
do it good to me.
I want you to do it to me.
You want them to know couch.
He said,
are you sure about that?
I still do it to me.
I,
you know,
I want to know how to feel.
And he goes,
you don't want to,
I can actually,
uh,
I got something better.
So we already steered away from it,
right?
So he says,
let me show you this.
And he walks over to his body,
they start talking to each other and then he walks away and in the corner he
stands like this.
Huh?
Like,
I mean crazy hiney run stalwarts,
his friend,
and he goes like this in midair.
He stops and he flies on the ground.
So he threw like Kung Fu forehands I didn't touch him.
Does it touch him?
I go,
dude,
I'm sold.
Do that to me.
Right.
I'm going to take you right now.
So I'm going to the corner.
And he goes,
yeah,
but you have to be a really angry.
I said,
excuse me.
Yeah,
really angry or otherwise it won't work.
I say,
your friend just did it right.
I said,
I'm,
I think I can better egg then your friend.
Don't worry,
I'll be in the zone.
And you know Billy bill,
he says,
no,
because if it,
if you're not real angry,
it doesn't work.
It needs to be that balance.
So I knew it was his way out.
So I walked over to him and I'm standing like this.
I say kick me into pills.
And he says what?
I said,
give me guys,
I'm really fucking pissed.
He didn't want to do it.
And needless to say,
I mean,
but they're idiots that truly believe that is true.
Well,
it's so easy to take someone who doesn't know anything like who's a student and
trick them like that and be a con man like that.
That,
and you know what the worst thing is?
There's teachers out there,
they give you a false sense of security and then they teach you how to defend a
knife.
You know,
grabbing the wrist.
I mean,
never did.
I mean it's so dangerous.
Life is dangerous.
Then a gun on a short distance at least at,
they teach them the wrong way and then something happens on the streets and he
pulls a knife and he goes to his buddy did step back.
I got it.
Yeah.
You know,
and they get killed.
Eddie Bravo has a crazy story about that guys full.
It's Eddie Bravo.
When he was first learning martial arts actually almost got into an altercation
before he knew Jujitsu.
He was first learning martial arts.
He really thought he was going to be able to like attack this guy and put him
away with some fake karate shit.
Yeah,
there you go.
See?
And he had a bad,
Eddie was first instructor was a fake guy and a guy said that he went to a,
was going to China to train with the monks.
Oh God,
we'll,
I'll be back in a week.
I'm going to China to train with amongst.
So Eddie was at the supermarket and saw the guys cars,
like what the fuck?
And he rented the guy at the supermarket.
It was supposed to be in China training.
What is the guy who killed her,
you know,
to fail Tori.
Yeah.
He would say that he will go into forest.
And he would fight the whole tournament and he would come back and yet leg these
bloodied up knuckles and suddenly your trophy
story.
Raphael Tory,
his name was not really Rafael Torres.
Oh No,
no.
That was a fake name.
He was a fake Brazilian Jiu Jitsu black belt.
And he had his friend,
Oh rob him off in the woods.
And I'm about to fight in a Kuma Tay Karate to,
to the death tournament.
It's so he's carrying this bag in the bag.
He had this fucking trophy already and it's like,
drop me off in the woods.
They're gonna meet me here and then I'm gonna fight for a couple of days and
I'll see you in a couple of days.
Yeah.
So then,
uh,
his friend comes back two days later,
pick them up.
Yeah,
I want everything.
Here's my trophy.
Like,
fuck,
are you retarded?
You brought that back,
that trophy in a bag.
But you know,
he came from that,
that era where you could get away with things.
People believe that.
I have a lot of guys who believe stuff,
you know,
it's the cover of magazines and they,
they're this and their that and they're nobodies.
Absolutely nobody's,
but people believe and directors believe that,
oh yeah,
here you go.
Oh my God,
this guy man is dangerous weight.
Galls golf claims.
Did you see the interview he did with Michael Chavela?
Oh No,
they're less in your face.
The thing is this,
the thing is this,
here I go back here.
I go back to,
did you ever compete?
No,
no.
But I,
I trained her without a guy should we would fight in Dojo.
We all know that finding in a Dojo and fighting under pressure in the cage or in
a ring,
whatever,
you cannot even compare to each other.
I always explain to my buddy Amir press always would say it.
You know,
if you take a two by four,
like a long 20 foot long,
right,
and you,
you have to walk over it,
it's an easy thing to do.
You just walk over.
It's 20 feet long now.
He put that same bar up about two buildings,
20 stories up,
and now you have to walk over there.
Now it's a whole different ballgame and it's not so easy anymore.
Now that's the same as if fighting and sparring.
Nothing compared how many Dojo fighters,
you know,
that terror.
Everybody including the professionals.
But when they find themselves,
they can't find their panic.
And that's what I always say until you never,
you,
you it,
you can never tell.
You can have a hundred blame,
but I don't care.
I'll go.
I got to see it.
I got to see you fight.
I don't believe people saying that.
You're good.
I want to see you fight none of training under pressure with people around.
So,
so important.
Wise words by boss Ruiz and gentlemen.
Learn knowledge,
respect,
uh,
follow Bas Rutten on Twitter.
It's Bas,
Rutten,
bas,
N m.
M.
Um,
the,
uh,
the website also.
What is your,
uh,
your website?
[inaudible] DOT com.
Okay.
Do trainer.com out to train or blog.com if you want to check out that one video
and then boss would
and bas rutten.com for um,
you,
you were website in elite mma.com.
So the,
the elite MMA gym,
elite Mma gym.com for your gym,
which is in thousand oaks.
Fantastic.
Jim,
you can't go wrong train there.
When his um,
Ramones brother back from uh Huh.
Ah,
I think a little bit of again next week and I'll be there every Tuesday and
Thursday,
uh,
at six o'clock.
If you want to commit people say okay,
the trailer with you.
I'm there.
I love to teach.
So it be their bas.
Rutten is on Facebook.
It's just slash.
Password.
All right my brother and honor as always and always a good time hanging out with
you say follow boss route and ladies,
gentleman,
that's again,
that's boss Rutan m m a on Twitter.
Thank you very much for tuning into the podcast.
My friends,
thank you to Squarespace for sponsoring the podcast.
If you go to squarespace.com,
forward slash Joe and a,
if you use the code named Joe Number three,
Joe three,
that's one word,
you will save yourself 10% off your first purchase on new accounts and includes
monthly and annual plans.
Thanks.
Also Ting for sponsoring our podcast.
If you go to rogan.ting.com you will save 25 bucks off of either a cell phone or
service and they have a full line of the best android mobile phones available.
Um,
so thank you to Squarespace.
Thank you to Tang.
Uh,
thank you to Onnit go to o n n I t use the code named Rogan.
Save yourself 10% off this Thursday night at the American comedy company in San
Diego.
Uh,
Brian Red Band will be there along with Yoshi.
Billy Bonnell,
Jason Tebow,
Tony Hinchcliffe.
Uh,
it's going to be a heck of a show and a,
it's one of the Ed,
one of the coolest clubs in incen southern California.
Um,
this Wednesday night in Pasadena,
uh,
I am at the Ice House Comedy Club with Ari Shaffir and Ian Edwards should be a
lot of fun.
It's a 10 o'clock show.
It's only 15 bucks and a Montreal this weekend is sold the fuck out.
So,
soccer boots.
Tough Shit.
We love you,
but we've got to sell tickets.
All right,
we'll see you guys.
Uh,
very shortly.
We have a,
a podcast.
Tomorrow I'm with Scott Sigler,
who is a,
an author,
writes a cool horror and fiction and I'm a and science fiction shit.
And then on Wednesday,
Shane Smith returns to the podcast.
Um,
so,
uh,
thank you everybody for tuning in and,
go fuck yourselves.
All right.
We'll see you soon.
Love.
Yeah.
Love Ya.
Like,
I love myself.
[inaudible].